je le rende sur les aspects financiers
et fiscaux de cette problématique avec
pour le ministère de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer monsieur Stanislas Alfonsi
adjoint au sous-directeur des politiques
publiques qui est Audi chez nous chef du
bureau de la réglementation économique
et fiscale de la Direction générale des
Outre-mer à dgom pour le ministère de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
Thibault Fiévet chef du bureau en charge
de la fiscalité énergétique
environnementale madame Noémie Berle de
la sous-direction de la fiscalité des
transactions fiscalité énergétiques et
environnementale et fiscalité
sectorielle pour le ministère de la
transition écologique et solidaire
Jean-François
Ossola adjoint la chef du bureau de la
planification et de la gestion des
déchets direction générale de la
prévention des risques et pour interco
outre-mer monsieur Maurice Gironcel
président et président de la communauté
intercommunale du nord de La Réunion
sinor et pour le syndicat intercommunal
d'élimination et de valorisation des
déchets de Mayotte
Sylvain 1976 monsieur chaneur Kassam
Directeur Général des Services je pense
qu'ils seront visioconférence ou qui
sentent en visioconférence ah pardon
excusez-moi monsieur
soyez bienvenue et oui
Mayotte fait une grande semaine sur
Paris sur la base de la trame qui vous a
été transmise nous allons donner
successivement la parole dans l'ordre
que je viens de vous indiquer si vous en
êtes d'accord pour une dizaine de
minutes les enjeux financiers sont
particulièrement importants sur ce sujet
et seront pris en compte dans nos
propositions et puis nous rapporteurs
Gisèle Jourda et Viviane Mallet vous
interrogerons ensuite pour approfondir
certains points donc je vous laisse la
parole dans l'ordre que j'ai indiqué et
puis je vous laisse le soin de VOUS
répartir le temps de parole
successivement
peut-être pour commencer vous êtes un
habitué maintenant merci monsieur le
Président effectivement on se voit on se
voit très régulièrement sur ce dossier
sur ce sujet et sur d'autres donc merci
évidemment de cette invitation à
échanger sur sur un sujet qui est très
important pour les pour les territoires
en général et en particulier pour les
territoires du tramarin c'est un sujet
qui
qui suscite des travaux nombreux des
travaux nourris c'est une une thématique
sur laquelle interviennent beaucoup de
beaucoup d'administrations alors vous en
avez trois qui sont présents aujourd'hui
c'est la direction générale de la
prévention des risques la direction
générale des outre-mer et nos collègues
de la direction de la législation
fiscale c'est un sujet qui intéresse
également la direction générale des
collectivités locales ne serait-ce que
parce que
est concerné au premier chef bien
entendu le budget des collectivités
locales et que ce sont nos collègues de
la DGCL qui détiennent l'essentiel des
des données en la matière et puis
également la direction générale des
finances publiques puisque la fiscale
étant étant majeur on en parlait on en
parlait à l'instant de façon un petit
peu informelle il est évident que les
collègues de Bercy seront probablement à
interroger au moins par écrit à
posteriori voilà ensuite on fera comme
vous nous indiquerez c'est-à-dire soit
on suivra le déroulé
on suit on commence maintenant où il y a
un mois introductif 2 si vous le voulez
avoir le même la même démarche que celle
de la semaine dernière ce qui est
peut-être plus efficace qui permettra
après au rapporteur de pouvoir revenir
sur les sujets pour approfondir très
échéances très bien on fait passer la
parole au parlementaire d'abord ou pour
non parce que vous commencez
le questionnaire qui nous a été transmis
est composé de plusieurs blocs il y a
quatre blocs le premier porte sur le
budget du service public des déchets le
second porte sur la TGAP qui
manifestement est un des cœurs du sujet
qui intéresse le Parlement juste titre
et les collectivités locales le
troisième porte sur l'Atom la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères et
enfin un quatrième bloc qui porte sur
des perspectives éventuelles de taxation
par d'autres par d'autres moyens
d'autres modalités
sur les les premières questions alors
moi j'interviendrai sur donc le premier
bloc est sur le budget du service public
des déchets donc nous avons là dans ce
premier bloc trois questions
j'interviendrai sur la première et la
seconde la DGPR prendra
la première la seconde sur la moyenne de
ce que peut représenter
le service public des déchets dans les
dans les budgets ultramarins la deuxième
sur le taux des couvertures de ce
service public par les les redevances et
le retour fiscal
sur la troisième ce sera nos collègues
de la DGPR qui interviendront sur le
coût moyen
de la collecte et du traitement sur le
deuxième bloc
la DLF sera à la manœuvre sur le la
question numéro 4 et sur la question
numéro 5 avec la DGPR
c'est il s'agit là des de la TGP ce qui
sera ce qui sera sans doute un morceau
important de nos échanges
sur le troisième bloc question 6
ce sera du côté ce sera de notre côté
mais également avec la
DDF si elle a des éléments
supplémentaires
idem pour la 7 la 8 des GPR la 9
ça sera plusieurs voies parce que on est
on est sur un une thématique enfin on
est sur un sujet qui est transversal
c'est à dire des évolutions potentielles
et enfin sur les deux dernières ce sera
la DGPR qui sera à la manœuvre
sur les deux premières questions donc je
vous le rappelle il s'agit de savoir
quelle part représente en moyenne le
service public des déchets dans les
budgets des collectivités
ultramarines et le taux de couverture
des coûts du service public des déchets
par les recettes dites ici propre alors
une partie substantielle de ces de ces
données comme je le disais dans mon
programme introductif se situe chez nos
collègues de la Direction générale des
collectivités locales nous avons pris le
parti de les contacter évidemment le
calendrier étant ce qu'il est vous le
savez bien avec le projet de loi de
finance les administrations sont
particulièrement mobilisées et dans le
temps relativement court qui nous était
imparti il aura été il a été compliqué
pour pour nos collègues de fournir tous
les éléments qu'on aurait voulu partager
avec vous aujourd'hui néanmoins on en a
obtenu une certaine partie et ils se
sont engagés évidemment à se tenir à
disposition du Sénat et des autres
administrations pour fournir des
éléments plus complets par la suite
le
fait que sur le coût moyen c'est à dire
la première question qui nous intéresse
des calculs de je dirais de relativement
bon sens permettent d'obtenir une idée
de ce que peut être le coût moyen pour
les collectivités
les collectivités ultramarines dans le
périmètre qui est traitée ici c'est à
dire principalement les départements et
régions d'outre-mer ont une population
qui est qui se situe aux alentours de
2002 2011 300 000 habitants ce sont des
collectivités dans lesquelles le coût
constaté de la gestion et du traitement
des déchets se situe dixit l'ADEME qui
avait été interrogé d'ailleurs par par
la commission au mois de mai au mois
d'avril à la fin du mois d'avril
lorsqu'on s'était vu la première fois
ce sont des collectivités qui ont un
coût qui se situe à un coefficient
aux alentours de 1,7 au dessus de de du
coup moyen constaté au National en
substance ça veut dire que on est entre
90 et 95 euros
par habitant et par an
pour le national la moyenne nationale et
qu'on est entre 160 et 165 euros
en coût moyen annuel
par habitant pour les outre-mer pour le
périmètre qui nous intéresse donc on a
un coefficient 1,7 entre le National et
les outre-mer
rapporter au budget tels que la logiciel
nous la fourni en cumulé pour les
collectivités qui sont concernées par la
thématique déchets c'est-à-dire qui
détiennent la compétence des chefs ce
sont principalement les EPCI qui
l’exercent puisque c'est le bloc
communal qui détient cette compétence
sur un plan juridique
attendu que c'est une que l'on doit
faire une moyenne c'est bien ce qui est
demandé lorsqu'on rapporte le coût moyen
de la gestion des déchets au budget
en fonctionnement de ces collectivités
locales on arrive à peu près un chiffre
de 10%
. ce que je vous donne ici est à prendre
avec beaucoup de réserves pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que c'est la DGCL
encore une fois qui peut détenir la
réalité des prix sur les chiffres que je
viens d'évoquer concernant le budget des
collectivités locales c'est une première
chose
deuxièmement parce que la digestion nous
a fait part d'un certain nombre de
précautions dans
dans l'appréciation dans l'appropriation
qu'on peut avoir les chiffres dont elle
dispose et qu'elle nous a fourni parce
que les remontées lui apparaissent une
fiabilité qui est perfectible
en clair elle n'est pas complètement sûr
de six chiffres parce qu'elle n'est pas
complètement enfin ces chiffres sont à
prendre avec certaines réserves parce
que leur fiabilité en remontée de la
part des collectivités locales n'est pas
pleinement garantie
le fait que si on est sur les équilibres
que je vous que j'expose on a un niveau
qui est relativement élevé
que je ne peux pas pour autant rapporter
à une moyenne nationale c'est-à-dire
autant je peux dire il nous semble que
on est à 10% ou légèrement au dessus de
10% autant je ne peux pas dire voilà au
National ce que c'est parce que je ne
connais pas je fais mon candidat ou pas
sur ce point là je ne connais pas le
budget global de fonctionnement de
toutes les collectivités du bloc
communal au plan national
comme je vous dis il faut un travail
plus plus long de recollement pour
arriver à produire ce chiffre là
encore une fois voilà on se tournera
vers les collègues de façon à obtenir à
obtenir des chiffres plus fiables donc
sur cette première question là voilà
c'est la première réponse que je peux
vous fournir encore une fois avec toutes
les réserves d'usage donc j'ai fait état
la deuxième question
porte sur les taux de couverture alors
les taux de couverture ils sont
variables selon les collectivités là on
va parler ce que je vais évoquer avec
vous ce sont des taux de couverture qui
sont
moyens
pour chacun des territoires que nous
allons évoquer
pour autant cela ne veut pas dire
que chacune des collectivités ou chacun
des blocs
constitués de collectivités chacun des
groupes de collectivités de chacun de
ces territoires à cette moyenne là
l'ADEME dans certaines de ces de ces
chiffres montrent que ces coups sont
extrêmement variables afin que les
toutes couvertures pardon sont
extrêmement variable et fait apparaître
une fourchette très très large qui va de
14%
à 92%
c'est à dire qu'il y a des collectivités
ou des groupes de collectivités pour
lesquelles le taux d'ouverture est
extrêmement faible
et d'autres pour lesquelles le taux de
couverture est
très satisfaisant et même très élevé
alors
par territoire voilà les chiffres que
nous avons pu
que nous avons pu établir ou retrouver
en ce qui concerne la réunion
nous serions un taux de couverture
tout cumulé c'est-à-dire les redevances
la théom etc
qui dépasse les 90% qui seraient à 91%
pour la Guyane ce taux de couverture
serait plus bas mais la Lune est en
scalaire on peut bien imaginer que étant
donné le faible nombre d'habitants qui
sont dans les faits en situation
d'aquitter leur redevance et leur taxes
selon étant enfin cette proportion est
en relativement faible par rapport à
d'autres territoires marins et encore
plus par rapport au territoire national
en sa globalité bien forcément ce taux
est plus faible et donc on serait à 73%
concernant la Martinique
alors là on a on a un chiffre qui est
issu du plan de prévention des déchets
qui a été établi il y a deux ans
et on est à un taux de couverture qui
apparaît dans ce plan à 71
pour cent
[Musique]
donc on le voit pour
les dromes Mayotte mise à part on se
situe
à 80% de moyenne globale
en allant de 70 à un peu plus de 90
je peux reprendre ces chiffres si jamais
si jamais je les ai dit trop vite ou
donner un petit peu dans le désordre
80 voilà Guadeloupe 80 alors je le
répète rapidement hein Google 80
Martinique 71
73 pour la Guyane et réunion 91
voilà
la réunion se situe de ce que nous avons
pu voir à des niveaux qui sont quand
même assez proches de ce que l'on
constate en moyenne nationale la moyenne
nationale est jamais à 100% c'est
rarement le cas évidemment puisque étant
donné la construction de la rentrée
fiscale et en termes de redevance sur
cette compétence comme sur d'autres la
plupart du temps le coût est légèrement
supérieur à rentrer ce qui est toujours
très très ordinaire lorsqu'on dépasse
les 90% et qu'on est entre 90 et 95 on
est proche des moyens nationales très
proches même
voilà ce que je peux vous dire sur ces
deux premières questions
c'est à dire sur
la part que représente en moyenne le
service public des déchets et sur les
taux de couverture dans chaque
territoire je ne répète pas les réserves
avec lesquelles il faut prendre ces
chiffres et je ne je ne répète pas la
difficulté
qui naîtrait d'une vision très
globalisante lorsqu'on parle de quatre
de 14 et qu'on va jusqu'à plus de 90 ça
veut dire qu'il y a une très très grande
diversité de situations selon les
collectivités et selon les EPCI enfin
selon les communes et selon les EPCI
considérés
voilà pour ces deux premières questions
la troisième question
principaux facteurs du coût moyen
supérieur de la collecte et du
traitement des déchets dans les
outre-mer ça va être nos collègues de la
DGPR qui vont prendre qui vont prendre
la main c'est une question que nous
avions en partie et même aux grandes
parties il me semble évoqué lors de
l'audition
à laquelle vous nous aviez conviés au
mois de mai ou à la fin du mois d'avril
donc il y a un certain nombre de données
qui seront répétés très probablement
voilà si Jean-François qui va prendre la
parole
bonjour à toutes bonjour à tous merci
sanislas pour
[Musique]
voilà ces premiers éléments alors sur le
sur le coût moyen supérieur qu'on peut
avoir en collecte et traitements des
déchets dans les outre-mer on a tous
conscience en effet et factuellement
voilà c'est un des des fondamentaux
qui qui perdure et qui peut
potentiellement avoir des marges de
manoeuvre à terme avec
voilà les dispositifs de la loi Haget de
2020 mais juste pour revenir
factuellement sur sur ce coût moyen
supérieur par rapport à la question que
que vous nous posez
comme l'a évoqué Stanislas sur le coût
moyen des des flûtes déchets ménagers et
assimilés on est à peu près pas très
loin au niveau moyen national de 100
euros voilà entre 95 96 euros par an par
habitant le coût moyen aidé sur cette
collecte et
les collègues des fuites déchets
ménagers et assimilés à l'extrême on
peut avoir alors tu as justement rappelé
une moyenne qui qui va généralement
autour de 150 euros par habitant côté
côté outre-mer on peut avoir des des
différences assez fortes avec
les derniers chiffres que l'on a de 2018
ou 2019 sur les enquêtes réalisées par
la dame voilà modecom et bien avoir un
coût moyen qui peut aller jusqu'à
193 euros pour les Antilles la Guyane
laxe carabine caribéen et plus impacté
sur ce sur ce coup là alors comment on
le sait les coûts et résulte à la fois
d'un niveau de service proposé à la
population des quantités connectées et
de l'efficacité des moyens pour
collecter transporter et traiter ses
déchets
alors comme exemple de facteurs
d'augmentation qu'on peut évoquer on a
ce qui est assez frappant c'est le
manque de déchetterie qui revient dans
beaucoup de territoires
qui peut expliquer le fait que notamment
professionnel
et qui renchérit ses coûts avec en
parallèle forcément une multiplication
des collègues porte-à-porte qui génère
beaucoup plus de déchets collectés et
augmente le coût du service public
en outre-mer également on a des
spécificités sur le fait que les
quantités d'ordures ménagères
résiduelles les encombrants et les DGV
et les déchets verts voilà sont en
quantité plus importantes
proportionnellement dans les territoires
ultramarins qu'en métropole
ce qui fait que on a également les
charges de transport traitement qui sont
1,3 fois supérieur à la moyenne
nationale avec des installations
multifilaires qui ne sont pas encore
effectives comme on peut la voir dans
l'Hexagone donc pour résumer en
principaux facteurs de coûts on a le
contexte insulaire générateur de prix de
prix de revient qui sont élevés les
facteurs climatiques
l'impact touristique qui qui pèse
également une multiplication des
services de collecte au porte-à-porte
des quantités donc importantes
d'encombrants de déchets verts d'ordures
ménagères résiduelles et des recettes
industrielles et des soutiens des échos
organismes qui sont plus limités
actuellement donc on va dire que en axe
de maîtrise de coût si on peut ouvrir un
peu cette question sur sur ce coup
supérieur malheureusement notre mère
pour l'instant et bien il y a peut-être
voilà les des choses à voir du côté on
va dire que c'est en termes d'écart de
coût qui est entre les dromcoms qui sont
différents parce que les territoires les
situations géographiques situation
politique sont différentes et on voit
qu'il existe des marges de manœuvre
ils sont c'est cool ne sont pas aussi
inductables mais on peut dire que sur le
partage d'expérience et de bonnes
pratiques dans des solutions plus
efficientes entre entre les dromcoms
c'est une piste en effet
mais qui est déjà qui est déjà qui est
déjà pratiqué une piste sans doute à
accentuer l'engagement politique fort
pour la maîtrise de cette dépense
publique passe aussi on l'a on l'a bien
entendu sur tout le territoire national
sur le dialogue avec les usagers et la
responsabilité le développement de
prévention pour limiter la production de
déchets et en mettant des pratiques de
collecte moins coûteuses alors c'est
vrai que le développement de filière de
recyclage local créatrice de richesse
d'emploi locaux le développement du
réemploi des Ressourceries il y a cette
impulsion avec la loi AGEC on sent qu'il
y a des pistes et on sent qu'il y a des
volontés très fortes sur le territoire
mais
il faut espérer que voilà le dispositif
de la loi AGEC notamment assez nombreux
pour l'outre-mer vont essayer de porter
d'améliorer cette efficience en termes
de coût et libérer aussi des marges de
manœuvre pour les collectivités
par rapport par rapport aux enjeux
du traitement du déchet qui sont
qui sont très forts qui sont à des
lors d'une visite en Martinique voilà le
mois dernier on m'a dit qu'il y avait
trois enjeux en gros pour Lille qui qui
peut revenir souvent pour qu'on peut
extrapoler je m'aventure mais pour pour
d'autres territoires de d'outre-mer il y
a les transports il y a l'eau et il y a
la gestion des déchets alors c'est vrai
qu'avec ça on couvre beaucoup c'est des
besoins essentiels et c'est vrai que en
termes de collecte et de coûts il y a
des outils et des partages expériences à
mobiliser avec la loijec qui ne peut pas
forcément tout résoudre mais qui offre
une impulsion pour ajuster aussi à terme
des dispositifs qui puissent aider les
collectivités à gagner des marges de
manoeuvre en termes de de dépenses sur
sur cette politique publique
donc si vous n'avez pas de question
particulière sur ce sujet mais peut-être
qu'on reviendra en fin de en d'échange
je vais passer la parole à mes collègues
de la de la DG Philippe pour
la TGAP qui est le un des gros sujets de
la matinée
[Musique]
merci beaucoup pour votre invitation
concernant le chiffre puisque c'était
l'objet de la quatrième question de la
TGAP quelques propos liminaires de déjà
premièrement pour rappeler que le
système déclaratifs ont évolué sur la
période sur laquelle vous nous
sollicitiez puisque le la TGAP était
initialement recouvrait par la douane et
qu'elle est depuis 2020 vous couvrait
par la DGFiP
les requêtes enfin de ce dans ce cadre
là les des requêtes sont en cours ce qui
fait que actuellement on a réussi à
réunir la chronique budgétaire sur les
années 2017 à 2020 et nos collègues sont
en train de de réaliser donc les
requêtes pour connaître les montants
afférents à 2021 et je vous prenne
m'excuser par avance mais pour une
raison selon liée à une coquille de
l'unes qui se trouve que nous n'avons
pas les chiffres concernant la
Martinique pour 2020 mais ce que l'on
vous propose c'est qu'on corrigera tout
ça dans un envoi chiffré avec les
statistiques à jour
en partant ça va pas être très forcément
très très agréable à la lecture
j'essaierai de faire le plus gros
possible et le plus synthétique possible
simplement pour vous présenter au moins
les grandes tendances et les grandes les
grandes données chiffrées que nous avons
pu réunir
sur les donc les rendements de TGP pour
les périodes 2017 à 2019 ou 2020
s'agissant de la Guadeloupe le rendement
évolue à la baisse puisque il était de
l'ordre de 6 millions d'euros en 2017 et
qu'il est de 5 millions d'euros en 2018
et 2019 pour finalement être de 4
millions d'euros en 2020
le rendement de la taxe en Martinique
suit une évolution sur sa période de
2017-2019 pureté dans la mesure où il
s'établit à 4 millions d'euros pour 2017
à 7 millions d'euros pour 2018 et à 5
millions d'euros pour 2019
pour la Guyane le lendemain est
relativement stable sur la période
compris entre de l'ordre de 1 million
d'euros en 3 millions et 1 million 2
pour la réunion sur la période 2017-2020
donc hors 2021 le rendement diminue
sensiblement de 11 millions en 2017 à 7
millions en 2020 avec des passages à 9
millions et à 8 millions en 2018 et 2019
et enfin pour Mayotte le rendement
évolue entre 700 000 et 500 000 euros
sur la période pour finalement remonter
à 750 000 euros en 2020
pardon
maintenant je vous en prie
[Musique]
sur la TGP oui
je me poserait des questions d'accord
avec plaisir juste sur le
pour plonger donc la discussion
simplement le point constat qu'on peut
faire ce que effectivement on a la
tendance est plutôt baissière qu'elle
est relativement différenciée selon les
territoires
on attend les chiffres 2021 on observe
néanmoins un décrochage au moins pour
les données pour les territoires sur
lesquels on avait donné on observe un
décrochage en tout cas pour la
Guadeloupe la Guyane et la Réunion pour
l'année 2020
décrochage qu'on n'est pas enfin qu'on
n'a pas encore expertisé à ce stade
notamment au niveau interministériel on
s'interroge sur les effets naturellement
de la crise sanitaire c'est le c'est le
premier la première raison qui nous
vient en tête mais à ce stade en tout
cas on n'a pas davantage de pas
davantage d'explication
voilà globalement sur le sur le sur les
données de rendement de la TGAP sur la
période demandée
je crois que je vais manger
on enchaîne et on reviendra à l'issue de
l'ensemble du tour de parole sur les
questions
tu commences
je reprends la parole donc sur la
question 5 par rapport
à la TGAP et le fait que
de maintenir sur les territoires
concernés le produit de la TGAP afin de
financer les actions en faveur de la
valorisation des déchets et d'économie
circulaire
la forme de cette affectation et de les
de fléchages qui pourraient s'opérer
alors pour un petit rappel par rapport à
propos introductif et qui reprend
les propos qu'il y avait pu être tenus
en partie en mai dernier lors de notre
la première audition et l'audition
inaugurale sur sur ce sujet et bien
voilà le principe en effet de la TGAP
que qu'on connaît tous qui est une taxe
environnementale qui s'appuie sur le
principe pollueur-payeur la partie
déchets représente je crois la
composante la plus la plus significative
si je me trompe pas
et le principe d'université du budget
état impose donc c'est de la non
d'affectation d'une possède à une
dépense particulière sauf à de rares
exceptions et en effet la TGAP ni
Déroche pas donc
parallèlement il faut rappeler que le
renforcement et la rationalisation de
cette composante des déchets de TGAP
conduit dans le projet de loi de finance
de 2019
voilà qui est voté voilà a conduit à
décider d'une trajectoire à la hausse
entre 2021 et 2025 progressive mais
assez significative pour inciter et bien
les apporteurs de déchets collectivités
entreprises à privilégier le tri et le
recyclage à l'élimination des déchets
donc stockage en installation voilà des
chaînons dangereux ou c'est dangereux ou
incinération cette mesure elle a été
prévue par la feuille de route économie
circulaire de 2018 qui est l'un des
aimants clés de la teinte des objectifs
nationaux et européens de la baisse de
quantité des des déchets mis en décharge
ou incinérés alors cependant afin de
tenir compte des caractéristiques
propres aux outre-mer des réflexions
sont appliquées et ont été renforcées
notamment par loi de finances
rectificative de décembre 2021 et
actuellement ces réfractions sont de
l'ordre donc de 35% pour
la Guadeloupe la Réunion et la
Martinique et de 75% en Guyane et
Mayotte là où les territoires là où la
TGP s'applique donc afin d'évaluer je
globalement prendre un petit peu plus de
faire une analyse un peu plus systémique
un peu plus globale le rapport coût de
la TGAP et des bénéfices dans les
territoires par rapport aux actions en
faveur de la valorisation des déchets
d'économie circulaire ce qui est
souhaité ce qu'on souhaite tous c'est on
peut se référer aux investissements qui
proviennent de voilà
du fond économie circulaire de l'ADEME
qui est nourri des ressources de l'État
qui
a pu bénéficier d'un effet plan de
relance en 2021 2022 boostant boostant
ses aides lames et on peut observer en
regardant en regardant ces données-là
que pour l'autre mère n'investissement
font économique circulaire et
supérieur au coût de la TGAP
véritablement on voit vraiment cet écart
là depuis 2020 on a en 2020 comme on n'a
pas les données vérifiées fiabilisées
côté 2021 juste pour 2020
l'ensemble de la télé Japon déclarés
pour l'année 2020 sur sur les cinq
territoires concernés et de 13 millions
13 millions 1 et on a des montants
engagés du fond économie circulaire de
la dame pour ses territoires à 22
millions deux donc sur l'ensemble on a
en effet
des projets qui ont été soutenus et
financés qui sont à une niveau un niveau
supérieur
voilà côté côté TGAP on pourra donner
territoire par territoire post-audition
ces données là pour enrichir votre votre
analyse et votre rapport bien entendu et
alors
on va dire en complément de ces de ces
fonds et bien il ne faut pas oublier
également que on a un périmètre large
pour le trômaire dans les financements
feders alors là on a dans on arrive dans
la période on a commencé la période 2021
2027 de ce cycle plus annuel voilà
pliancée qui
qui sont tout à fait opérants et
disponibles pour soutenir les projets
locaux contrairement à la métropole ou
les installations de gestion des déchets
par exemple où les CSR ne sont plus
financés par ce font fédère
y compris côté adème c'est plus
compliqué
l'outre-mer
gare de cette gare de cette cart là pour
soutenir pour avoir ces soutiens
soutiens européens également donc c'est
c'est aussi à prendre en compte dans le
retour on va dire sur investissement si
je puis dire par rapport voilà c'est
assez territoires
alors sur les questions suivantes qui
relèvent plus de la taxe d'enlèvement
des ordures ménagères je passe la parole
à mes collègues
[Musique]
la même façon que pour les chroniques
budgétaires 2020 et 2021 surtout de la
TGAP nos collègues de la DGFiP sont en
train de réaliser les chiffrages donc
malheureusement je ne sens pas en mesure
ce matin de vous transmettre les
chiffres et du taux moyen de la théom
dans les outre-mer à comparativement à
la métropole et des taux de recouvrement
de la théorème sur cette dernière
question
j'attire juste l'attention sur le fait
que une des principales difficultés pour
réaliser ce chiffrage on va essayer de
réaliser mais qui va forcément évident
c'est que la terre étant adossé à la
taxe foncière il n'est pas forcément
évident dans les requêtes informatiques
d'isoler uniquement l'atte homme par
rapport aux déclarations
et je passe la parole à mon collègue de
la DGPR
sur la théomacitative Jean-François
c'est
de mon côté
alors sur la théom incitative à ce jour
à notre connaissance le seul territoire
ultramarin avoir étudié le sujet La
Réunion
la direction régionale de l'ADEME avait
fait réaliser une étude d'opportunités
puisque c'est c'est un processus long
pour en effet pour l'implémenter
ça se fait sur
sur plusieurs années
généralement qui qui dépasse voilà qui
qui dépasse les deux trois ans et donc
l'étude d'opportunité réalisée par
l'ADEME en pour les collectivités de
pour l'ensemble des collectivités de la
Réunion et date de 2013 mais il n'avait
pas donné suite
depuis notre connaissance avec celle de
l'ADEME toujours à la Réunion ce sujet a
été étudié donc par trois EPCI la
communauté d'agglomération
intercommandée intercommunale du Nord de
la réunion avec 200 000 habitants pour
trois communes
qui qui voilà qui étudier avec un
engagement dans un projet de mise en
œuvre de la théom incitative qui n'a pas
encore avancé mais bon ils sont engagés
dans le processus on a un deuxième autre
PC de la Réunion la côté Est avec un peu
moins d'habitants 127000 habitants pour
6 communes qui n'ont pas donné de suite
positives et pour le troisième EPCI
concerné celui de la communauté
d'agglomération Sud à peu près
équivalente en termes d'habitants et de
communes que que cette de l'est
elle souhaitait aux dernières nouvelles
lancer une expérimentation sur la sur la
théomie
mais donc côté outremer euh voilà il n'y
a pas de d'effectivité de la théomie on
est encore à des études
[Musique]
et loin de la mise en œuvre
pour pour la Réunion côté national on a
des objectifs qui sont qui sont assez
assez élevés finalement
de généralisation de la théomie
je crois que c'est 15 millions
d'habitants en 2025 on est actuellement
on est actuellement en dessous en
dessous de 10 millions on est entre
je crois vers 7 ou 8 millions
d'habitants qui sont qui sont concernés
on voit que c'est que c'est pas évident
il y a la il y a la question de
l'appliquer cette tarification
incitative à la redevance à La Réole et
pas la théom plus les exemples qui sont
plus on va dire plus courantes
actuellement sur le territoire national
et concerne plus l'incitation
l'incitativité sur la partie réaum mais
c'est vrai qu'elle a elle a des effets
certains sur les fictivité des choses
elle avait fait certains sur en tout cas
sur la baisse en effet des ordures
ménagères résiduelles mais on va dire
qu'elle est plus facilement applicable
dans un territoire qui dispose des
filiales de validation de traitement
d'un réseau de déchetterie on va dire
plus plus conséquent
que sur un territoire voilà plus isolé
en outre-mer qui nécessite aussi des
infrastructures des installations
voilà traitement d'un réseau de
déchetterie qui soit qui soit conséquent
parce que sinon
voilà l'application est sans doute moins
évidente et sans doute plus progressive
et ce qui explique le fait que il n'y a
que les réunions qui pour l'instant
a lancé un processus d'étude dans
certains EPCI sur ce sur ce domaine là
très bien merci Jean-François pour cette
question numéro 9 alors comme je le fais
presque à chaque fois maintenant je
viens avec un chef de bureau différent
de la Direction générale des Outre-mer à
qui je propose son petit baptême du feu
face à face à au parlementaire donc
cette fois-ci je suis venu avec le chef
du bureau de la réglementation
économique fiscale c'est très formateur
et comme ça ça permet à chacun de
prendre par aux échanges donc je passe
la parole là-dessus à sur cette question
neuf à Tony chez nous bonjour merci
merci Madame et ses notes merci mesdames
messenatrices de participer à mon
baptême du feu sur le la question de de
l'écotax à l'importation qui serait lié
à l'octroi de mer alors
c'est une c'est une proposition qui nous
semble rencontrer quand même plusieurs
obstacles d'abord alors il vous le savez
l'octroi de mer c'est une taxe qui a
deux objectifs principaux financement
des collectivités locales et le soutien
la production à la production locale
ce sont déjà deux objectifs qui parfois
peuvent entrer en contradiction lorsque
la Région
souhaite par exemple
exonérer un secteur économique c'est
aussi des effets elle renonce à des
recettes et donc ça ça peut être parfois
enfin ce sont deux objectifs qui peuvent
entrer en tension
et nous sommes que ajouter un troisième
niveau d'objectif qui serait plutôt un
objectif environnemental ce qui semble
en fait ressortir de cette proposition
ne rendrait pas ou rendre moins lisible
encore moins lisible qu'elle ne l'est et
plus complexe cette octroi de mer
il est généralement admis que un
dispositif de politique publique et
j'inclus la fiscalité en tant qu'outil
de politique publique
dès lors qu'il a plus d'un objectif il
est difficile de le rendre de le
satisfaire et de rendre cette ce
dispositif relativement efficace donc
peut-être
là il est souvent tentant d'en demander
beaucoup à l'octroît de mer mais de ce
point de vue il nous semble que il
faudrait plutôt explorer d'autres
d'autres pistes pour atteindre cet
objectif je nous voyons aussi un autre
une autre difficulté qui n'est pas des
moindres c'est une question de
compatibilité avec le droit de l'Union
européenne donc vous savez que donc
cette octroi de mer a une double
autorisation à la fois par le Conseil de
l'Union au titre de l'union douanière et
par la Commission européenne la
direction générale de la concurrence au
titre du droit des aides d'État
il serait difficile
probablement que la Commission
spontanément la commission verrait cette
taxe additionnelle comme une taxe
d'effet équivalent en fait qui serait
contraire à la réglement au droit de
l'Union européenne et donc il nous
faudrait justifier cette cette écotaxe
auprès de l'Union européenne ce qui
serait pas simple et à tout le moins il
faudrait l'appliquer au marchandises à
la fois importé mais aussi qui serait
produite localement pour éviter des
accusations de discrimination ce que
nous reprocherait évidemment la
Commission européenne
et puis enfin il y a aussi un autre
argument c'est que
cet écotaxe additionnel rend chérirait
le coût des produits importés ce qui est
dans le contexte actuel en fait est un
peu un peu complexe voilà difficilement
acceptable par nos concitoyens
donc je dirais quand même sur ce sujet
pour ouvrir ce qui est aujourd'hui
est-ce que ce que ce qui évoque la
question sur une modulation des
comment dire du de la taxe en fonction
des difficultés à recycler ou à traiter
qu'aujourd'hui la région où la
collectivité territoriale peut moduler
les taux à la hausse ou à la baisse de
tous les produits
de la nomenclature douanière en fonction
de ce qu'elle considère comme pouvant
être plus nuisibles ou négatif à
l'environnement par exemple donc ça
c'est vrai que je pense qu'il y a un
travail à faire aussi avec les ou que
les régions peuvent prendre s'emparer de
ce sujet et prendre des initiatives
certaines le font d'ailleurs
et globalement aussi on peut s'appuyer
sur des dispositifs nationaux peut-être
que cet objectif
de de
que pourrait remplir cet écotaxe pour
être aussi satisfait par rapport à
travers le développement des filières
REP ou aussi des systèmes
d'écoparticipation par exemple voilà
est-ce que tu veux dire un petit motif
du ministère de l'économie et des
finances sur les difficultés aussi de
de pratiques en fait peut-être pas très
vite pour compléter son partage
naturellement tous les points que tu as
évoqué c'est plein pour pour indiquer
que si une télé s'il devait être
réfléchi à une telle éco contribution il
mentionnait des critères
environnementaux et toute la difficulté
nous semble-t-il c'est justement de
d'identifier ces critères
environnementaux
ça pose une difficulté juridique c'est à
dire qu'il faut réussir à trouver des
critères qui soient qui ne portent pas
atteinte au principe d'égalité donc il
s'applique à tout à tout type de produit
et il s'appose une difficulté pratique
et qui est d'identifier justement ces
fameux critères
une fois qu'on a dit alors on peut on
peut en imaginer on peut imaginer des
équivalents des missions de CO2 on peut
ce genre de choses une fois qu'on les a
posé il faut faire en sorte nous
semble-t-il d'une part que c'est que ces
critères soient facilement applicables
pour les opérateurs et d'autre part qui
permettent des contrôles par
administration fiscale pour s'assurer
justement que une ladité
éco-constribution et verser à mon droit
en tout cas il nous paraît relativement
complexe d'imaginer un tel dispositif
qui soit à la fois
relativement fluide en tout cas simple
pour les opérateurs et de la même façon
relativement simple à contrôler pour
l'administration fiscale pour éviter
simplement les effets de fraude qu'on
pourrait constater
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux sur
cette question 9 la question 10 sur les
consignes et également la question 11
seront principalement traitées par la
DGPR
merci
alors sur l'idée et la solution de créer
des consignes sur certains produits
polluants comme les batteries de voiture
afin de dissuader leurs abandon sur la
voie publique
alors sur les batteries plus précisément
la révision du règlement européen sur
les batteries a été lancé au premier
semestre 2022 sous la présidence
française de l'Union européenne donc
avec des discussions au niveau des États
membres des du conseil et elles sont
toujours en dialogue et
actuellement en discussion en trilogue
entre la Commission le Conseil et le
Parlement européen
discussions longues et avec beaucoup
d'enjeux mais qui qui prévoit dans la
proposition initiale de la Commission et
qui sera retenu à terme une disposition
qui qui viendra
apporter une voilà une flèche à l'arc de
réponse sur ces problématiques de
batterie sur la
prévision de la mise en place d'une
d'une rép d'une filière repe pour
l'ensemble des batteries alors filière
represabilité énergie du producteur qui
par le principe universel des reps
s'appliquera comme les autres sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
et en cas de retard constaté une des
dispositions de la loi agecte de 2020
permet et bien de prévoir un plan
d'amélioration des performances de
collecte et traitement des déchets dans
ces territoires afin qu'elles soient au
moins égal à celle atteinte en moyenne
en métropole dans les trois ans suivant
la mise en place du plan on a beaucoup
de renouvellement de cahiers des charges
de REP en cours et puis de nouvelles
réponses en train de s'implémenter là
dans notre période de 2021 2023 2024
et on va dire que ces plans de
rattrapage outre-mer vont porter une
attention ils vont et vont permettre de
guider
de guider et de renforcer l'attention
que les éco-organismes doivent doivent
avoir dans leur implication et dans la
mise en oeuvre des rêves sur les sur les
territoires autrement autre marin on a
une une dispositif législative qui nous
donne plus d'armes si je puis dire sur
pour
inciter et accompagner les les
organismes à appliquer
et rattraper
au mieux
la moyenne nationale
après parallèlement sur la mise en place
d'un système de consignes
indépendamment de la problématique
batterie
en outre-mer on peut dire que c'est
forcément un dispositif on parlait des
surcos tout à l'heure pour le traitement
des déchets forcément il engendrerait
des coûts plus élevés qu'en métropole
c'est pour ça qu'il faut en tout cas de
notre côté il est clair que il est
difficile de l'envisager uniquement
localement mais de se référer un
dispositif national de consignes pour
amortir les coûts alors en 2023
on rentre dans une une phase de sur les
emballages en termes de consignes de
réflexion et de mise en oeuvre d'une
expérimentation de consignes sur les
emballages donc ça ça va permettre un
peu de et qui concerne l'ensemble du
territoire national avec en effet des
péréquations à trouver avec avec
l'outre-mer et donc c'est on va avoir un
une sorte de test et de défis devant
nous pour l'application de la consigne
alors sur ces sur ces emballages mais
qui qui vont pas mettre de nourrir les
débats
ensuite sur la question 11
sur la fiscalité minorée ou incitative
par rapport à la TVA pour favoriser le
réemploi
et l'expérimentation possible en
outre-mer alors la baisse de la TVA sur
les activités de de réparation qui est
pilier de l'économie circulaire c'est
vrai que c'est une demande qui assez
récurrente du Parlement
mais pour rappeler pour rappeler
l'historique c'est le fait que seuls les
produits qui sont listés dans la
directivité TVA directive européenne
soit éligibles à taux réduit au niveau
du droit européen
donc je crois qu'on l'a sur le le cuit
on les textile mais on n'a pas su pas
sur l'ensemble et donc ça limite un peu
cet effet là qui pourrait qui pourrait
être demandé il faut rappeler aussi que
les territoires
guyanais et Mahoré sont exemptées de TVA
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça
on a la notre loi à Jacques qui prévoit
deux types de fonds à partir de 2022
d'abord les fonds réparations pour
différentes catégories de produits
soumis aux filières REP qui permettent
qu'une partie des coûts de réparation
auprès des réparateurs labellisés soit
pris en charge par ses fonds donc
l'avantage c'est de baisser directement
le prix pour le consommateur avec ce
fond réparation
il y a également
un autre d'autres fonds les fonds
réemploi qui eux sont destinés aux
acteurs de l'économie sociale et
solidaire
et ces fonds sont adaptés conformément
donc aux quantités employées qui se font
fixées dans le cahier des charges de
chaque filière REP donc il est prévu
ainsi que les filières qui produisent
des déchets
pardon qui produisent des produits
électriques électroniques des meubles et
des textiles ou des articles de sport de
bricolage et de jardinage qui ensuite
voilà se finit son péché contribue à ces
fonds à hauteur de 5% de leur
contribution à la filière REP donc ces
fonds permettront notamment de soutenir
les acteurs qui réparent les objets et
leur donne une deuxième vie soit pour
être donné soit pour être revendu
alors les fonds réemploi qui sont mises
en ils doivent être mis en place dans
les six mois de l'agrément de la filière
REP et donc pour les déchets
électroniques les détroiteux qui vont
électroniques ont le déploiement au
niveau national est en cours et il sera
complètement opérationnel en 2023 pour
le fond réemploi des trois œufs je
laisse peut-être la parole à mon
collègue de la de la DG fi pour
voilà pour les précisions sur la TVA ne
souhaite
bref précision sur la TVA comme tu l'as
indiqué le droit de l'Union européenne
le tourisme de l'application la tour
réduit de TVA qu'au petit service de
réparation portant sur certains biens
c'est-à-dire les bicyclettes les
chaussures et articles en cuir les
vêtements et les linges de maison
prévoit pas effectivement d'autres
d'autres dispositifs sur les sur les
autres sur les autres produits
ou de là au-delà de ce point
relativement au droit de l'Union
je tenais souligner que les produits
reconditionnés
peuvent déjà faire l'objet d'un
dispositif favorable en matière de TVA
qui est le régime de la marge
bénéficiaire c'est à dire que la TVA
sous certaines conditions ne
s'appliquent qu'à la marge et pas à
l'ensemble du prix du produit
dernier dernier point par rapport à
cette à cette proposition de TVA sur le
réemploi le fait que le terme réemploi
en soi
recouvre instant de réalité qui sont
parfois difficiles à traduire enfin
complexe à traduire fiscalement et qui à
notre sens
introduirait effectivement des
difficultés tant du point de vue des
professionnels que de l'administration
en effet le point de savoir comment
déterminer le périmètre de la nature des
prestations en cause savoir est-ce que
c'est de la est-ce que c'est de la
réparation proprement dite est-ce que
c'est de la remise à l'état neuf est-ce
qu'on parle de fortunitures de matériaux
est-ce qu'on parle de fournitures de
prestations autant de notions qui en TVA
ont leur importance et
voilà qui pose qui pose dans la mise en
oeuvre par rapport à la proposition qui
est de d'introduire un tour réduit de
TVA
se poserait nécessairement le cas
échéant le dernier point qui nous
semble-t-il et est également d'irrément
au-delà du premier argument qui pour
nous est déjà fondamental qui est celui
de l'atteinte au droit de l'Union
c'est le fait que
factuellement même si pour les raisons
que je viens d'exposer sur les
difficultés à définir ce qu'est le
réemploi
il est probable intuitivement en tout
cas que une exception large du terme de
réemploi a duré un coup budgétaire
important pour l'État si si cette
disposition était adoptée
merci beaucoup a priori nous sommes
allés au bout du questionnaire avec
encore une fois toutes les insuffisances
de nos réponses liées en grande partie
au cours des lait que nous avons eu pour
traiter ces questions dans un dans un
cadre calendaire qui est qui est marqué
encore une fois par le projet de loi de
finance et nous sommes à votre
disposition bien entendu merci ce que je
propose c'est de continuer le tour de
table des deux derniers intervenants
alors je ne sais pas si Monsieur
Gironcel est connecté pour interco je ne
vois pas à l'écran donc on attend
peut-être qu'il se reconnecte si je
pense que vous êtes connecté monsieur
gironcelle je vais vous laisser la
parole avant de laisser la parole à
Monsieur Kassam de Mayotte
[Musique]
il y a ce problème
de faire que nous devons traiter nos
déchets disons sur notre territoire et
pour cela je pense qu'il faut que on
arrive à maîtriser la question des
traitements et de variations des déchets
de boutons sur notre territoire
donc ce qui veut dire il faut une
réflexion également ok moins de déchets
qui rentrent sur le territoire
des déchets et il faut également une
réflexion pour qu'on puisse avoir aussi
dans nos territoires la possibilité de
commercer avec nos pays d'azote ce qui
ne fait pas malheureusement parce que
nous savons donc nous sommes donc
tributeurs une certaine pratiquement
essentiellement nos implantations
viennent de l'Europe et bien sûr de la
France hexagonale donc
nous sommes dans des zones
disons tropical
avec nous sommes pas dans l'atmosphère
Nord et nous avons un gros gros problème
également d'humidité notamment pour nos
déménagères l'exemple qu'on a ce
sentiment du centre multifilaire c'est
donc au top au niveau en ce qui concerne
et le traitement et la valorisation des
déchets parce que une cohésion également
du CSR nous produisons également bien
sûr
du compost et tout mais il y a le gros
gros souci c'est que nos déchets quand
ils arrivent dans les centres de
traitement ils sont beaucoup plus
humides et y compris les cartons et
surtout concernant le carton nous
pensons que nous devons également avoir
une réflexion au traité nos cartons sur
place également peut-être en le faisant
parce que quand c'est très humide
n'arrive pas à développer une filière ou
on n'arrive pas à les exporter ce serait
peut-être de développer également voir
comment qu'on peut faire du CSR avec
également les cartons parce que ça
revient à la même chose les parents les
cartons c'est donc
la biomasse et donc au départ donc ce
serait à nouveau le faire en sorte que
on puisse bien les valoriser
nous devons également c'est peut-être
c'est ça aujourd'hui je souhaitais dit
également la délégation du Sénat qui
était venu à la Réunion c'est de dire
nous devons nous inscrire dans nos zones
respectives en gros dans nos bassins
on peut dire ça comme ça
et qui peuvent nous offrir
des perspectives de traitements de
déchets nous avons
donc à trouver un partenariat avec le
pays et là aussi favoriser ce
partenariat il faudrait que au niveau
législatif puisse avoir cette
possibilité là pour que le partenariat
qu'on a dans nos zones de respecter les
géographique et bien pour une
rentabilité en quelque sorte de nos
processus de
de traitement et par la raison de
déchets j'ai un exemple très précis on
abordait je crois que c'était imposé par
nos collègues concernant la
problématique des déchets dangereux
nous exploitons les déchets dangereux de
la Réunion ou Mayotte déjà
notamment l'Europe et pas seulement au
Havre
pour quelle raison qu'on pourrait là
aussi réfléchir soit
notre réunion voire même également
d'autres pays je prends l'exemple de la
Réunion parce que je suis à la Réunion
pour qu'on puisse traiter les
problématiques y compris des dangereux
dans nos pays de la zone géographique il
y aurait un coût notamment de transport
sur le frère ça coûte très cher en même
temps ça sera c'est des créations
d'emploi localement donc c'est une
réflexion qu'on devrait mener je pense
et d'avoir la possibilité donc de
traiter nos déchets y compris dangereux
sur nos différents passants
de l'océan et ensuite il y a dans nos
îles en particulier
nous avons un gros gros problème de
foncier
pourquoi parce que nous sommes
restreints la Réunion par exemple c'est
une idée de 1500 km² avec 900000
habitants nous avons une zone habitée
qui est en gros le littoral et un petit
peu sur la mi-hauteur
un pays très montagneux donc
nous avons pas beaucoup de fonciers et
quand on crée un centre isld ou isdu
forcément
c'est proche des habitations
donc il faut là aussi qu'on ait une
approche différente par rapport à la
France hexagonale
on ne peut pas non plus c'est mon
appréciation on ne peut pas non plus
nous appliquer des taxes exactement
comme en France hexagonale pourquoi je
dis ça
bonjour aujourd'hui nous savons que nous
va nous dire par exemple la Réunion vous
avez le 900000 habitants une seule
uveuse suffit est-ce qu'il faut prendre
en compte que la Réunion par exemple
nous avons et bien la situation
géographique fait que le Nord et le Sud
c'est pas évident de circuler
et en même temps donc il faut pas avoir
une approche peut-être pas par rapport
au nombre d'habitants mais une approche
également dans nos pays respectifs je
crois qu'on a réunion une approche et
bien tenant compte de notre situation
j'ai entendu également tout à l'heure
dans un des collègues
en parlant les priorités qu'il y a donc
des Antilles qui sont le transport l'eau
et les déchets à la Réunion c'est pas
forcément dans cet ordre là nous avons
bien sûr
que vous êtes en avance par notamment
parce que vous avez mis comme des
réseaux de transport commun beaucoup
plus performant que chez nous
vous avez nous nous avons notamment des
problèmes qu'on a parce que nous avons
une démographie qui continuent
de plus dans deux générations on aura le
million d'habitants et donc forcément le
deuxième problème qui vient c'est le
premier logement et nous avons
actuellement
34000 à 35000 demandes de logement en
souffrance et alors on construit
quelques deux maximums par an de
logements sociaux donc on a des visites
énormes bien sûr il y a le problème des
déchets on est d'accord et je répète
encore une fois le problème de du
foncier avec l'aménagement
vient après c'est ce que je viens de
dire tout à l'heure voilà un petit peu
moi ce que je voulais dire dernier point
vous avez parlé dans une tarte
incitative nous avons sur la signor nous
sommes en train de délire une petite
opération disons dans un quartier ou
revoir la faisabilité on n'a pas encore
le retour et c'est vrai que c'est pas
c'est pas ça on est bien d'accord
[Musique]
c'est la loi qui va être évoquée pour
les biodéchets
ici le médecin
pour l'instant moi et
c'est vrai que il faudrait réfléchir et
pour faire en sorte que nos pays
soient pris non pas directement ne
serait-ce par exemple on abandonné trois
mères il y a que 3 mètres donc on voit
bien qu'il faut avoir une approche
différente y compris en matière de
déchets pourquoi je dis ça je suis
également président du syndicat
d'électricité de la Réunion nos pays
sont dans ce qu'on appelle
discuter parce que la transition
énergétique
nous avons nous adopté le plan de Tramel
de l'énergie et ce qui ressort c'est que
nous sommes dans une zone non à la
connectée ce qu'on appelle les indemnis
donc en gros d'avoir la même approche
concernant la problématique des déchets
c'est-à-dire on doit faire en sorte que
on puisse être et valoriser nos déchets
le plus possible globalement voilà ce
que je veux je tenais à dire
je suis moi mais je voulais aborder ce
mois-là de façon globale au niveau de la
Réunion merci de votre attention merci
Monsieur gironcelle et dernière
intervenant pour ce tour de table avant
de laisser la parole à nos deux
rapporteurs monsieur Kassam de Mayotte
donc Mesdames Messieurs les sénatrices
sénateurs merci pour cette invitation
enfin donc je transmis les remerciements
également de la part de mon Président
ou samedi Abdallah alors pour cette
intervention j'ai préparé un support je
sais pas si on est en mesure de le
projeter
très bien
monsieur gironcelle si vous pouviez
juste couper votre micro ça éviterait
qu'on puisse voilà merci beaucoup
[Musique]
alors en attendant que la régie
effectivement de projette donc le
support
alors effectivement j'ai fait le choix
de de préparer un support parce qu'on va
parler chiffres on va parler fiscalité
finance donc c'est beaucoup plus
agréable de d'avoir des projections
graphiques sur ces questions j'ai cru
comprendre également que côté bureau
ministériel ils avaient quelques
difficultés à avoir des chiffres pour
Mayotte bon je les ai préparés voilà
pour pour les années antérieures ils
sont assez fiables pour l'année actuelle
puisque j'ai également fait l'effort de
projeter sur sur 2022 c'est relativement
approximatif mais donne quand même un
éclairage assez intéressant
donc je vous propose de basculer sur la
première partie alors j'ai repris
évidemment les différentes parties du
questionnaire
ou effectivement je réponds pour une
grande partie au diffra une question
posée sur la sur la première partie donc
les questions d'efforts budgétaires
consentis par les collectivités membres
alors je me suis focalisé sur les
budgets des EPCI puisque effectivement
au sens des compétences elles détiennent
principalement donc la compétence
collecte des traitements de déchets
dans le cas de Mayotte c'est le syndicat
donc sidévam sainte-camix qui assure
donc la essentiellement la mission
collect et traitements déchets à
l'exception de l'académa qui gère seule
ça compétence collecte la cathédra donc
qui regroupe la commune de Mamoudzou la
capitale de Mayotte et la commune de la
mini ce que l'on peut voir c'est que on
a eu effectivement en 2019 et même
antérieur puisque les intercours
immergés à partir de 2015
un début un peu chaotique ou
effectivement souvent les intercos les
efforts sont plus ou moins élevés
en l'occurrence pour pour la communauté
d'agglomération du Grand Nord on était à
80% d'efforts de contribution dans les
finances de du service public de gestion
déchets qui finalement a voyagerait
enfin convergerait et c'est valable
également pour les autres intercours
vers une moyenne autour de 50 %. voilà
qui est finalement ces efforts de
contribution directe des budgets des
intercos représente et jusqu'à cette
année en tout cas la principale le
principal poste de financement de du
service public de gestion déchets alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que forcément
ça pèse au niveau des contributions des
intercos également au détriment des
compétences que doivent exercer ces
intercommunalités je rappelle
développement économique développement
touristique aménagement habitat extra
c'est cette forte contribution qui
représente pour le cas du cinéma 60% de
son budget forcément entraîne aussi une
forme de dépendance de la question de
trésorerie puisque effectivement on est
on subit les alias de décaissement et
d'encaissement provoqués finalement par
les intercommunalités membres du coup
l'autre partie c'est 40% donc c'est la
taxe dans le ventes du ménagère qui est
ici beaucoup plus intéressantes en
matière de trésorerie puisque le
versement est mensualisé
alors on a un sentiment fort au niveau
local de saturation au niveau de ce
levier de financement voilà donc
je ça a détruit la presse locale en 2020
mais on a subi une forme de crise
de confiance de la part des
contributeurs EPCI sur 2020 et on sent
effectivement qu'on a atteint je dirais
le niveau haut de l'appel des fonds
dans des contributions des interminités
est-ce qu'on peut passer à la deuxième
donc deuxième levier de financement
donc la page suivante voilà donc la taxe
dans les zones ménagères j'ai également
fait les Ford production de quelques
chiffres ici donc on a alors suivant les
taux effectivement voté par les les EPCI
qui ont fait le foie effectivement de
d'instruire d'instaurer ces taxes donc à
savoir le site EVAM qui est donc la
courbe au dessus donc 14 en 2019 qui qui
converge vers 19
100% en 2020 la communauté de communes
de petit air qui est donc la deuxième
courbe passant de dans une dizaine de
en pour cent jusqu'à 16% pour cette
année et l'académa qui a instauré cette
année donc la taxe dans le livre du
ménagère qui qui a fait grimper donc le
taux moyen au niveau du département donc
qui a fait augmenter donc de 14% et qui
vous le voyez à travers donc le
l'histogramme passons donc en 2019 à 25%
de couverture par la théom jusqu'à
probablement plus de 50% puisqu'encore
une fois on est sur une projection
budgétaire de cette année donc on attend
de la fin d'exercices 2022 on serait
effectivement à la moitié voire plus de
la moitié du financement par la théorème
alors ça voudrait dire que du coup cette
année on basculerait vers
une configuration où la taxe d'ambiance
déménagères devient le premier poste de
financement du de la gestion donc public
de gestion des faits alors
je rappelle effectivement que cette
compétence est partagée donc il y a des
mains pour la collecte et puis si des
femmes pour la collecte des traitements
je rappelle que la mise en place de la
fiscalité à Mayotte puisque la taxe dans
les bandit sur du ménagère s'appuie sur
la taxe
foncière et alors
donc cette mise en place a été un peu
voilà un peu chaotique en tout cas du
sentiment local c'était le cas donc
depuis 2014 ou effectivement les valeurs
locatives ont été excessivement élevées
à les ont été corrigés partiellement via
la loi égalité réelle en 2017 pour un
abattement de 60% de la valeur locative
ceci dit le les chiffres sont quand même
encore bien haut donc on a une valeur
locative relativement élevée par rapport
au standard nationaux pour une
population que je rappelle à 77% en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté les mahorés
en l'occurrence sont pour leur très
grande majorité propriétaire de leurs
biens
donc une pression fiscale clairement
importante
au vu de la situation sociale des
contribuables largement documentées au
niveau de la presse locale donc pour le
cinéma mais pour les autres
collectivités donc qui qui perçoivent la
om bah la question de la pression
fiscale est clairement pesante difficile
également de ne nous appuyer sur ce
levier de financement pour les
prochaines charges en matière de gestion
donc de déchets alors en matière de donc
d'évolution des charges j'ai fait un
focus et évidemment c'est l'objet donc
de cette de cette matinée un focus sur
le la TGAP qui qui pèse effectivement
sur la charge de traitement alors ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai produit ici rapidement
c'est donc au niveau de la courbe c'est
l'évolution alors projetée alors déjà
rétro tout ce qui est avant 2022 et
plutôt fiable mais tout ce qui est après
évidemment est une pro au regard de la
dynamique d'enfouissement des déchets
alors c'est le tonnage enfui et sur ce
tonnage effectivement s'applique la TGAP
qui qui augmente chaque année
effectivement je prends 2025
ce qu'il faut comprendre ici c'est que
il sera difficile de
d'inverser la tendance et forcément
c'est déjà fait à Mayotte en particulier
payé par le cinéma puisque c'est la
seule collectivité compétente en matière
de traitement déchet et vous le voyez en
fond donc au niveau des histogrammes on
a la dégradation progressive des
épargnes donc épargne de gestion épargne
brute et par net du sidévam alors ici
l'homme n'est pas encore endetté donc
c'est pour ça qu'effectivement l'épargne
lunettes et égal quasiment à l'épargne
brut
corriger donc des dotations
d'amortissement mais alors vous voyez
qu'effectivement une décroissance forte
alors cette simulation ne prend pas en
compte l'évolution des contributions des
intercos et l'évolution des taux parce
que j'ai rappelé juste en amont que on a
un sentiment de saturation au niveau de
ses leviers alors effectivement sur ce
scénario on voit que des 2024 2025 on
basculerait sur des épargne négatifs
donc nécessité effectivement de d'avoir
une approche je dirais
différente sur la question alors
peut-être par un levier de financement
supplémentaire peut-être avec un moyen
beaucoup plus efficace pour orienter le
comportement des des producteurs de
déchets et donc des consommateurs
la question incitatif à Mayotte bon
évidemment ça a été rappelé tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas eu d'études encore
d'effectuer ceci dit le cinéma m'adopte
en collaboration avec l'académa donc son
programme local de prévention des
déchets assimilés des déchets ménagers
assimilés
et il prévoit donc une action en ce sens
sur la mise en place d'études au niveau
de la fiscalité fiscalité incitatif
néanmoins du sentiment général niveau
local on y confie pas beaucoup d'espoir
puisque je pense que vous connaissez la
situation de Mayotte on a quand même
beaucoup de population informelle qui
pèse et qui ne contribue pas aux
finances locales et la question de la
taxe foncière s'appuie également sur le
cadastre qui également n'est pas
suffisamment à jour ça voudrait dire
qu'une grande partie de la population ne
sera pas concernée alors qui est
productrice de déchets ne sera pas
concerné par la fiscalité institutive
c'est pour ça qu'on plutôt on réfléchit
à d'autres solutions notamment des
solutions de gratification du geste de
tri avec interface tissu donc commerce
de proximité
évidemment des négociations sont en
cours avec Citeo qui donc les
co-organismes en charge de des gens des
déchets emballages mais bon malgré
l'expérimentation effectivement sur
cette
dispositif
c'est plutôt voilà c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt voilà mal parti
donc face à ces niveaux de contribution
fiscale ou direct des budgets des
intercours voilà la question de
financement s'impose alors dernière
diapositives effectivement pourquoi
pourquoi pas envisager les quotas alors
évidemment plusieurs freins plusieurs
contraintes ont été posées ce matin sur
cette écotaxe ceci dit je rappelle que
enfin j'estime qu'il est quand même
intéressant puisqu'il permet un couplage
entre l'activité de gestion déchets et
l'activité de consommation donc puisque
en vérité les deux domaines sont dans
une même réalité je rappelle et le
problème ici qui se pose pour la gestion
des donc la finance publique de gestion
déchet c'est que on s'appuie un peu trop
sur le patrimoine parce que bon que ça
soit via la tor ou on se base sur la
taxe foncière ou que ce soit les
contributions directes des interco qui
eux-mêmes ont une fiscalité propre et
donc puis sur le patrimoine local bah
voilà il y a une forme d'inadéquation au
niveau des dynamiques donc peut-être
envisager alors cette solution des
contacts c'est très intéressant puisque
permet de prélever dans la dynamique
d'importation et donc de consommation
une portion pour financer la dynamique
donc de gestion d'échec
mais la question se pose de la
gouvernance est-ce que c'est une
gouvernance d'inspiration de droit de
mère et donc que les décideurs locaux
ont un peu plus la main pour fixer le
niveau de taxation et fixer aussi les
différents produits et donc déchets une
fille concernés
quelle entité bénéficiaire de ces
produits sachant que effectivement au
niveau du train de mer mais c'est le
bloc communal qui est bénéficiaire je
rappelle que le site Eva étant
gestionnaire du des déchets et donc et
membre du bloc communal puisque
émanation de des communes des intercos
donc pour pas envisager une fine et
là-dessus une perspective pour pour le
vie de financement bon au regard
effectivement des contraintes posées
pour la mise en place de cette ecotaxe
et mais du point de vue du cinéma mais
des points de vue de des maorilles des
acteurs locaux et je finir là-dessus en
vérité le véritable problème c'est les
moines contraintes qu'on pourrait poser
aux écoralisme puisque Mayotte est alors
je voilà j'exagère un peu à peine mais
plutôt de déserter pour les écoralisme
on a effectivement une présence d'écossi
de d'écosystème de Citéo et quelques
efforts par par d'autres égorganismes
mais
assez timide
pour ne pas dire voilà manque de volonté
significatif là-dessus et la doléance
finalement de au niveau local c'est
pourquoi ne pas envisager de vraiment de
creuser des moyens de contraintes de
pénalité vis-à-vis de ces organismes qui
se mobilisent pas assez sur les
territoires tamarins je sais qu'il y a
un rapport édité en 2018 par rapport
Vernier qui est qui documente longuement
finalement ces moyens de pénalité
possible
vis-à-vis de ces organismes puisque
finalement c'est l'autre partie ici on
arrive à structurer et mobiliser plus de
dégorganismes sur le territoire au
niveau des différentes filières on a
moins de riz finalement la charge
d'enfancement et donc la charge de DGA
paye pourquoi voilà c'est peut-être
l'autre levier qui serait pertinent de
creuser en tout cas un autre sens donc
et je et dernière proposition là-dessus
bah le rapport vernis parle de de
définir plus précisément des auditifs de
taux collectes valorisation et taux de
recyclage bah nous notre demande c'est
peut-être l'envisager territorialement
de point de vue des Outre-mer puisqu'on
est noyé dans le pot commun national et
Mayotte ou la réunion ou les Antilles ne
pèsent pas gros lorsqu'on raisonne et
niveau national donc plutôt que de fixer
des objectifs nationaux fixer des objets
territorialisés voilà bah je vous
remercie du coup pour pour ce temps
d'écoute et à votre disposition pour les
éventuelles questions
merci beaucoup je vais maintenant
laisser la parole à Gisèle Jordan et
Viviane Mallet pour aider les collègues
qui sont présents et puis saluer la
présence de notre collègue matin de
Sidrac qui est présidente du groupe
d'études économie circulaire au sein de
la Commission sénatale comme du
développement du territoire aménagement
du territoire pardon et développement
durable donc je vais laisser la parole à
Gisèle et Viviane
tout d'abord
vous remercier messieurs et Madame pour
donc
les éléments que vous avez porté à notre
connaissance même si compte tenu des
contraintes que vous avez évoquées vous
n'avez pas pu avoir tous les éléments
dans leur exhaustivité
néanmoins par-delà tout cela à moi je
n'ai pas 20 ce qui me concerne sur la
mission qui est la nôtre
si nous avons donc diriger vers vous ces
questions c'est qu'il remontait des
territoires des préoccupations et
malgré la technicité de vous répondre on
est quelque peu en tout cas moi je reste
un peu sur ma faim notamment en matière
donc de de TGAP puisque
lorsque nous avons auditionné lorsque
nous avons été sur place il y avait donc
une demande récurrente d'avoir donc un
allègement de cette taxe de cette taxe
pollueur-payeur parce que ça pesait sur
les intercommunalités certaines
organismes qui étaient contributeurs de
cette taxe à cette taxe donc
mon questionnement serait de savoir
quel correctif quel
ne pourrait-on pas avoir un moratoire
sur ces questions-là de manière à
permettre au territoire donc
ultramarins qui qui perçoivent et qui
sont donc redevables de cette TGAP de
pouvoir donc mettre et investir dans le
perfectionnement donc de de la chaîne
liée aux déchets que ce soit donc la
collecte le traitement et la
valorisation après donc des des déchets
traités ça c'est voilà c'était un peu
au-delà de l'aspect technique quelle
piste peut-on développer donc sur
sur cet aspect là ensuite sur le le
aspect qui était revenu je m'excusez moi
j'ai surtout une tête ce que en tant que
hexagonale j'ai j'ai entendu sur les
différents territoires et et au cours
des auditions que nous avons faites
la question de la consigne qui est de
qui est qui
a été prégnante est-ce que ça peut être
donc un outil
les
en matière d'incitation même si le
questionnement qu'on a eu
Paris pas donc
d'une grande pertinence mais comment
pourrait-on en trouver en tout cas
trouver donc certains ne
correctifs finalement pour permettre aux
territoires donc ultramarin de de régler
certaines de des problématiques parce
que
il paraît évidence quand on parcours
certains territoires quand on voit les
efforts fait mais à côté la situation
endémique liée donc à l'accumulation des
déchets on a parlé tout à l'heure des
des VHU ou en tout cas
des batteries etc c'est quand même un
problème récurrent qui a un impact comme
on le disait lors de la Table Ronde de
précédente qui avait donc très plutôt à
la santé il y a quand même des des gros
enjeux il me semble l'outil de de fiscal
à un certain moment donné devrait avoir
certaines modulations voilà un petit peu
moi le le renvoi que je souhaitais avoir
pour qu'on puisse avancer par de là
les schémas étriqués liés donc à la
fiscalité mais à un moment on a su
trouver ou des moratoires ou des ou
certains assouplissements parce qu'il y
a quand même des réelles contraintes
celles notamment liées donc au transport
qu'évoquaient donc Monsieur de La
Réunion donc mais il y a des questions
de stockage il y a des questions de
transport il y a des coûts et des surcos
parce que suivant les zones traversées
ça pèse sur donc je crois que
le but en tout cas de notre mission
c'est d'essayer de tenter d'apporter une
certaine éclaircissements et de voir
donc par rapport au dernier volet que
j'aborderai qui est celui des filières
REP mais qui sont pas développés partout
parce que tout le monde n'a n’est pas là
quand vous êtes vous en êtes avoir des
difficultés même à collecter
que vous avez à peine donc enclencher le
phénomène du traitement il y a très très
peu ça a été dit par l'un d'entre vous
d'ailleurs de de
chaîne de déchetterie de valorisation
c'est très peu mis en place
bon il y a des territoires sur lesquels
il n'y a absolument aucune filière donc
le mise en place aurait parce qu'ils
n'en sont pas là si on n'a pas traité
les deux premiers
maillons il est très difficile de passer
aux autres et ensuite il ne faut pas non
plus pénaliser son ceux qui ont été plus
loin et ceux qui ont été plus loin et ce
qui se retrouvent contraints parce
qu'ils sont
en termes d'enfouissement dans les
derniers qui sont
à mettre pour pouvoir il y a ce
cristaire de l'insularité voilà je suis
désolé j'ai été un petit peu plus large
dans mon intervention mais je souhaitais
quand même avoir de votre part puisque
vous êtes des hommes et des femmes à
guéris quelques pistes pouvant sous
tendre nos questionnements qui ne sont
pas que fiscaux et exclusivement fiscaux
mais à un moment il va falloir à mon
sens regarder moratoire ou allègement de
ce type de fiscalité je pense qu'on ne
pourra pas passer outre ce type de
recherche
merci Madame et messieurs pour
les précisions que vous avez apportées
c'est vrai que c'est depuis le mois de
mai ou avril on se rend compte assez
souvent et merci monsieur le Président
gironcelle d'être là cette table ronde
donc
vous savez mon cheval de bataille bon
c'est véritablement la tigeac puisque
j'ai toujours été
sollicité par les maires de la Réunion
et les présidentes de PC d'ailleurs sur
cette tâche qui est jugée
pour nous injuste et c'est vrai que lors
des auditions on a eu
le rendu similaire des départements de
de la Guadeloupe et de et de la
Martinique la Guyane et la et Mayotte
s'en sortent un petit peu mieux puisque
l'année dernière dans il y a deux ans
ils ont une réfraction supplémentaire
nous c'est vrai on a eu 10% de plus
l'année dernière donc de 25 on est passé
à 35% de réfraction c'est c'est vrai
mais bon pour cette année moi j'ai les
chiffres pour la Réunion
[Musique]
pour
2021 c'est 10 millions
environ pour la Réunion et ça va passer
à 12 millions 8 l'année prochaine et si
on est toujours tout tient enfouissement
en 2025 ça va atteindre 16 millions
d'euros et c'est vrai que c'est 16
millions d'euros mais on préférerait les
garder sur notre territoire pour être
plus vertueux c'est ce qu'on essaye de
faire et bon alors vous je sais que dans
la discussion toutes les fois c'est on a
pris du retard oui mais vous voyez quand
même les contraintes ou les contrats
géographiques les contraintes de terrain
les contraintes de de transport
puisqu'on transporte beaucoup plus de
même de poids aussi si on veut Monsieur
Jean Ancel disait tout à l'heure que le
carton bah il est plus humide donc c'est
vrai que quand on l'a enfoué bah écoute
il est plus lourd il doit coûter plus
plus à l'enfouissement mais c'est vrai
que on a pris du retard les filiales
rêves ce sont des déployés quand même
progressivement et moins vite aussi que
sur l'hexagone
donc moi cette taxe je trouve qu'elle
est elle est injuste je me demande si
tout à l'heure on a discuté en off
est-ce qu'on devrait plus l'appeler TGP
est-ce qu'on devrait changer nous
laisser le temps de s'adapter puisque en
fait
les projets sont en cours maintenant je
pense que chaque territoire a quand même
vu les enjeux chaque territoire a
compris qu'il fallait faire des efforts
et on essaye de le faire c'est vrai que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que la les
tonnes d'enfouissant n'avaient c'était
dû à la crise certainement l'année
dernière sur la réunion était la même
mais moi je regardais ce matin sur le
Bassin parisien c'est pareil donc on
vous aide pas pubertueux que nous
voulait dire mais bon j'essaye de
regarder ce qui se passe aussi et
comment ça en s'organise dans les dans
les autres départements sur l'hexagone
voilà donc moi ma réflexion c'est
toujours sur la TGAP comment on peut
faire pour laisser et pouvoir à ce que
les EPCI ne soient pas enclin à
va augmenter la théorème parce qu'en
fait aussi avec l'inflation avec
le contexte économique ça retomberait à
terme sur sur les
usagers donc c'est quand même assez
quand on parle d'économie quand on dit
que les produits chers la charité de la
vie et tout on peut pas on peut pas se
permettre d'augmenter les taxes après je
voulais revenir sur les les taxes pour
les batteries c'est moins cher je les ai
parlé l'autre jour mais c'était pas une
taxe supplémentaire que je voulais
mettre en place c'était dans le prix de
la voiture en fait c'était se dire il y
a une consigne pour cette batterie ou
peut-être un bon d'échanges c'est pas
c'est pas faire monter le prix
effectivement on en est pas là et
surtout pas il faut il faut surtout pas
le faire mais c'est peut-être un bon
échange vous avez une voiture vous avez
le bon échange vous changer la batterie
bah vous êtes obligé de la ramener quoi
en fait parce que ce bon il est là quoi
autrement on vous donne pas une batterie
de d'essayer de voir comment on peut
faire sans je le redis faire évoluer les
prix et puis après les filières de rêve
se mettent en place pour les batteries
pour toutes les batteries je voulais
savoir pour les batteries au lithium
parce qu'on a quand même une grosse
problématique je crois que les batteries
auditionnent d'après ce que je comprends
pas les traiter pour l'instant il y a
pas je sais pas mais je sais que nous on
a un problème pour l'exportation qui va
apparemment j'ai vu la presse ce matin
ça devrait un petit peu se débloquer
entre Mayotte et la réunion et un bateau
serait affronté mais bon c'est c'est le
Béa je pense qu'on va le faire et c'est
une bonne chose mais les batteries au
lithium ne pourront pas être traités sur
le territoire donc le le problème va
être récurrent
mais là en gros un petit peu ce que je
voulais dire puis sur les bios déchets
je suis d'accord avec mon avec Monsieur
Gironcel le Président on n'est pas
encore prêt
il y a le problème à revoir avec les
bailleurs sociaux il y a pas mal de
problématiques à avoir c'est vrai qu'on
fait beaucoup de portes à porte et vous
nous dites qu'il y a un coup c'est vrai
mais si on faisait pas ce porte à porte
je pense qu'on retrouverait encore un
petit peu plus de déchets dans la nature
la taxe incitative oui c'est vrai qu'on
tous les territoires ils pensent mais
moi j'ai vraiment
peur que
on se retrouve avec des sérieux on a on
a beaucoup quand même de de personnes
qui brûlent encore ça se voit
régulièrement et qu'on se retrouve avec
des des gens qui refont des des petits
brûlent chez eux pour avoir un petit peu
moins de 2 kg
voilà en gros un petit peu ce que moi
j'avais à vous soumettre merci
je vous laisse peut-être répondre avant
de où on prend une autre question
peut-être Fanny ça va être très bref
président
le courte intervention pour remercier
les intervenants de
lumière sujet le sujet de cette date-là
la délégation outre-mer un sujet ou
combien important et sensible celui du
traitement des déchets et encore plus
sensible lorsque le regard de sa partie
sa partie fiscale
tout à l'heure j'ai failli bon dire
quand j'ai entendu encore qu'il n'y a
pas de chiffre à Mayotte
c'est comme si on ne prenait pas la
température ou ont cassait le
thermomètre c'est la meilleure façon de
montrer qu'il n'y a pas de maladie or
pour vous être déplacé mesdames les
rapporteurs vous avez constaté à quel
point
ce problème est prégnant préoccupant
dans le territoire le plus pauvre
d'Europe
c'est le DG ça a rappelé tout à l'heure
que ce samedi 7%
des citoyens vivent en dessous du seuil
de pauvreté territoire gangrené par
des problématiques qui sont perçues
comme plusieurs jantes la sécurité l'eau
l'immigration clandestine et du coup ces
sujets là
aurait tendance passer sous le radar
surtout si on n'a pas de chiffres donc
merci
d'y avoir remédier les
collectivités produisent ces chiffres il
y a des délibérations la preuve vous les
avez exposé ici
c'est délibérations sont transmises aux
préfet donc moi si j'avais
un cri d'alarme aujourd'hui à vous
passer Madame Monsieur de des ministères
vous en parlez de ces chiffres là
Mayotte
l'image souvent que que j'emploie c'est
un petit bébé qui vient de naître dans
dans l'évolution institutionnelle de
notre de notre pays donc ce bébé
mériterait plus d'attention
dans
ces grandes difficultés
et non ce qu'on peut ce n'est pas ce
n'est pas à vous mais comme vous
représentez les ministères ici voilà au
lieu de davantage sans préoccuper et
tenir compte de la situation pour éviter
que les choses soient pires c'est c'est
l'inverse qui qui se produit
aujourd'hui à l'image de de l'excellent
exposé du directeur de service
[Musique]
nous voyons qu'il y a de l'ingénierie
locale localement avant vous pouvez
peut-être dire on n'a pas de remontée de
terrain le travail n'est pas
suffisamment fait aujourd'hui on ne peut
pas on ne peut plus dire dire cela je
terminerai en
rappelant la problématique ici du
foncier qui influe directement
sur la taxation des déchets il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui
70%
70% des terres ne sont pas immatriculées
ce qui fait que seulement 30%
de la population subit une pression
fiscale mais sans précédent et
insupportable et et
[Musique]
il y a une réforme en cours pour
poursuivre l'immatriculation et le titre
commun des voilà de
des parcelles foncières mais c'est
l'occasion aujourd'hui il faudra je
saisis tous les occasions pour remettre
sur la table ce sujet d'acuité dans la
délégation a commencé à s'intéresser
depuis 2015 des pistes des pistes ont
été
trouvés ici ont été suggéré ici
certaines ont fait l'objet
de loi mais d'autres restent à mettre à
mettre en place les solutions sont là
face aux difficultés et moi mon propos
consistait à nous dire ici
collectivement que allons vers ces
réponses qui qui existent et ça commence
par avoir les chiffres hors ces chiffres
là existent sur le territoire de Mayotte
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président et
je remercie également les
deux de ma société
merci Madame merci messieurs pour vous
présenter de ce matin moi je souhaitais
évoquer un point qui est revenu dans
chacun de vos propos notamment autour du
droit européen sur un certain nombre de
sujets et qui s'appliquent à au
territoire évoqué ce matin puisque
beaucoup de nos territoires ultramarins
sont aussi des des régions ultra
périphériques de l'Europe et donc à ce
titre là leur incombe un certain nombre
d'obligations mais également aussi des
fonds qui sont censés entre autres aussi
à promouvoir les emplois création
peut-être d'un certain nombre de
ressources aussi localement dans tous
ces territoires du coup je pose une
question peut-être un peu naïve mais on
voit et vous l'avez également évoqué et
cela a été rappelé par mes collègues il
y a des spécificités ultramines entre
autres liés à l'insularité bien
évidemment au climat donc des
spécificités très particulières y
compris entre deux zones de région
ultramarines qui sont nous avons de
l'hémisphère nord nous avons de
l'hémisphère sud enfin voilà il y a un
certain nombre de particularités et
en réalité ce mois dans mes modestes
déplacement que j'ai pu faire
revient souvent en fait le l'idée de
manque de suffisamment de masse
critiques en réalité pour créer des
unités parfois de traitement de nos
déchets localement sur ces territoires
là parce que moi qui suis par exemple
sénatrice des Yvelines si j'ai des
difficultés sur les déchets qui
pourraient y avoir sur mon territoire
ben je peux m'adresser au voisin au nord
au sud à l'ESTO à l'ouest ce qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué pour nos
territoires ultramarins donc je voulais
aussi éventuellement vous poser cette
question là y a-t-il éventuellement un
mécanisme que nous pourrions porter nous
la France au sein de l'Europe pour
permettre à nos territoires ultra
amarins de pouvoir pourquoi pas créer
aussi localement dans le cadre de ces
fonds européens qui ont vocation à en
réalité des investissements dans nos
territoires des unités qui pourraient
des unités pionnières sur un certain
nombre de spécifiques que ce soit le
recyclage que ce soit les CSR des unités
voilà chaque territoire selon ce dont il
a besoin et voir pourquoi pas comment on
peut traiter le plus localement possible
tous ces déchets parce que je reprends
l'exemple de la Réunion qui est
d'autres territoires aussi qui est
profondément impacté par ne serait-ce
que sur les déchets dangereux de devoir
à chaque fois les ramener les les vers
la vers l'Hexagone donc voilà c'était
une question que je souhaitais vous
soumettre et une réflexion aussi à
partager avec vous tous je vous remercie
merci monsieur le Président de m'avoir
cédé la parole
merci bonjour et merci pour vos propos
éclairants pour rejoindre ce que disait
Martha Sidrac à savoir télémy j'aurais
aimé partager l'expérience de
Saint-Barthélémy puisque nous sommes un
petit territoire de 21 km² et que la
problématique des déchets s'est posé
depuis fort longtemps nous avons fait le
choix non que d'organiser une plateforme
de tri mais de revaloriser la majorité
de les déchets qui peuvent le faire par
l'accinération avec avec traitement des
fumées et production d'énergie donc nous
avons une
usine d'incinération qui est couplée
avec une
usine de production d'eau potable de
désalinisation d'eau de mer puisque sur
notre territoire nous n'avons pas de
source nous n'avons pas d'eau douce et
une deuxième
usine vient d'être inaugurée
d'accinération qui sera couplée à une
production enfin générateur production
de l'énergie donc
comme disait ma collègue Vivienne Mallet
alors elle parlait de la TGAP peut-être
pour pourquoi pas je l'ai quelques temps
la TGAP qui permettrait aux
collectivités d'investir dans ce triple
d'installation puisque l'usine la
dernière usine d'incinération que nous
venons de 16 millions d'euros donc cela
m'a été appelé et pour rejoindre aussi
maranta de Sidrac c'est que avec les
aides les aides européennes il y aurait
peut-être possibilité de se diriger vers
cette voie et d'aider puisque cela
élimine l'enfouissement puisque la
majorité beaucoup de déchets sont
incinérables après reste à traiter ce
qui ne l'est pas donc nous avons aussi
développé une filière
ferraille pour tout ce qui concerne les
VHU qui est exporté une partie vers les
États-Unis une partie vers vers
l'hexagone et concernant les batteries
au lithium nous avons passé un avec les
concessionnaires qui récupèrent ces
batteries parce qu'il est vrai que nous
n'avions pas de filière enfin nous ne
trouvions pas de filière de traitement
de recyclage de ces batteries donc les
concessionnaires ont accepté de les
récupérer et ils en font ils ont font
leur affaire voilà donc je voulais
partager cette cette modeste cette
expérience de manière à je comprends les
problématiques des territoires et
essayer d'apporter une aide à nos
territoires ultramants
merci monsieur le Président
[Musique]
et merci à tous pour vos interventions
et pour vos questions qui nous
permettent d'échanger sur un sujet qui
ne sera pas
purgé et résolu pleinement aujourd'hui
on s'en doute bien ça fait plusieurs
mois qu'on se concevoir qu'on se parle
il y a eu des rapports dans le passé il
y aura celui que vous allez que vous
allez finaliser
c'est un travail qui se poursuivra
évidemment et nous serons à disposition
de chacun et de tous pour pour y
contribuer alors sur la je vais
reprendre dans l'ordre et évidemment je
passerai la parole à au collègues des de
la DGPR et de la DNF pour pour compléter
en particulier sur le sujet de la TGAP
on peut se poser la question de savoir
si c'est une taxe qui
mérite d'exister sous cette forme si
elle doit être transformée si elle doit
être à maudit dans un sens dans un autre
il y a un élément fondateur dans le
process
politique ou administratif du
fonctionnement de notre pays c'était
tellement fondateur c'est la loi de
finance et donc il revient bien au
parlementaire à un moment donné de dire
on voit ça on change
les administrations
feront bien volontiers ce que le pouvoir
politique dans toute sa légitimité
dictera au travers du vote de loi de
finance
aujourd'hui donc la Tiger à pied pour
l'instant existe peut-être qu'elle
mérite d'être transformée et encore une
fois ce débat peut contribuer à nourrir
la réflexion sur le sur cette question
la TGAP dans sa ces modalités de
déclinaison et d'applications outre-mer
a fait l'objet d'adaptation y compris
récemment adaptation qui ont été permise
et je mets mes paroles en cela dans
celles des rapporteurs tout à l'heure
qui ont été permis ces adaptations parce
que les territoires ont démontré
qu'elles étaient dans des dynamiques qui
donnaient un horizon
les projets commencent à sortir ils sont
pointés ils sont identifiés les retards
quel qu'en soit les motifs pris par ces
projets pour nombre d'entre eux ne sont
plus de nature ces retards à empêcher
leur existence et donc ça met les
interlocuteurs qui demandent ces
adaptations je dis en situation de force
mais en situation plus confortable pour
évoquer dans le concert global
l'éventualité de nouvelles adaptations
pourtant il faut pas perdre de vue ce
qu'est l'outil fiscal dans notre
fonctionnement alors on parle des
déchets et des déchets en outre-mer mais
le l'outil fiscal il est utilisé par la
puissance publique au travers encore une
fois des lois de silence puisque l'impôt
il est voté à cette occasion là
dans tous les domaines de la vie
publique soit de manière encouragée de
manière à dissuader il a déjà appelé par
nature c'est un impôt qui a pour
vocation de tuer son assiette
c'est bien le but c'est à dire de créer
une forme de pression comme il peut y
avoir éventuellement je sais pas moi une
surtaxe sur les véhicules très polluants
pour dissuader tout simplement leur
achat et pour dissuader leur mise en
circulation comme il peut y avoir un
certain nombre d'entraves en matière de
redevance ou en matière fiscale à telle
ou tel comportement que l'on estimerait
de voir être corrigé je pense je sais
pas moi
au logement par exemple où on met une
taxe sur les logements vacants en se
disant bah comme ça on va mettre
davantage
de logement sur le marché et donc on va
faire baisser les prix enfin bref c'est
une des cercles vertueux que l'on
connaît bien donc la TGP elle a cette
vocation là ensuite ces modalités
d'application sur des territoires comme
des territoires ultramarins méritent
forcément d'être interrogés et c'est
pour ça que les demandes de dérogations
elles sont toujours elles sont toujours
examinées et portées dans la mesure du
possible avec avec
conviction alors je voulais sur bien sûr
la DGPR et l'ADLF revenir sur la
question de la TGP sur les taux de
réfraction plus favorables qui ont été
obtenus
précédente et les perspectives
éventuellement qui pourraient être assez
pour la suite
je reviens d'un mot sur Mayotte
alors je veux pas je veux pas lancer de
polyning mais
je m'approprierai pas le terme d'enfants
ou de bébé
voilà c'est je pense qu'il faut pas
il faut pas inffantiliser les
territoires voilà les ce serait prendre
à mon sens mais on est libre de partager
une opinion différente
ça serait
ce serait une approche un petit peu
paternaliste que je ne veux pas que je
ne veux pas faire mienne voilà ce sont
des
interlocuteurs responsables que nous
avons à Mayotte c'est un territoire qui
est rentré récemment dans un cadre
institutionnel qui est le sien
actuellement c'est à dire celui d'un
département de plein exercice
le politique encore une fois là aussi a
fait ses choix en toute légitimité il ne
va pas de le remettre en cause ses choix
donc Mayotte doit être traité de manière
responsable avec toute l'attention qui
doit être apporté un territoire qui est
et là je vous rejoins monsieur le
sénateur fragile c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
un retard de développement à Mayotte que
l'on constate tous des taux de pauvreté
très élevés que vous avez rappelé qui
ont été rappelé par d'autres
et donc c'est une situation qui
nécessite
une attention plus spécifique plus
particulière et nous nous efforçons tous
les uns et des autres
d'apporter cette attention toute chose
étant en perspective c'est-à-dire que le
travail des acteurs locaux est pas
effectif le travail des administrations
est perfectible le travail du Parlement
évidemment est probablement pas
affective la preuve c'est que nous
continuons tous à débattre et à exister
si les choses étaient finies et bien
nous-mêmes on aurait moins de de
légitimité et de pertinence dans notre
existence en tant qu'institution donc
Mayotte nécessite d'être accompagné du
côté du ministère des Outre-mer ce sont
des des préoccupations que nous avons vu
et que nous continuons d'avoir de
manière extrêmement prégnante Mayotte
concentre une grande partie de notre
activité
il y a eu des choix qui ont été proposés
notamment pour des adaptations
législatives avec une aide plus
spécifique à apporter au territoire je
pensais au projet de loi qui a été
initiée l'année dernière et qui on peut
on ne peut que le constater inchiné n'a
pas été n'a pas été validé par
certains par le Conseil départemental en
particulier absolument c'est vous le
rappelez à l'instant et on ne peut que
le regretter c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
a voulu apporter du côté du ministère
des outre-mer et du côté des
administrations et du côté du
gouvernement une aide plus spécifique en
disant attention là on a un cas
particulier Mayotte doit être traité de
manière
totalement respectueuse de ces des
prérogatives confiés au territoire en
toute responsabilité voilà mais doit
être aidé de manière très spécifique et
donc
prenons prenons chacun le parti d'y
apporter une pierre supplémentaire
je me rappelle que lorsque la vie
négative du conseil départemental a été
a été formulé nous étions à la veille du
passage devant le Conseil d'État
oui on était quand même très très loin
ça ne veut pas dire que le process était
terminé ça veut pas dire ça ça veut dire
que les bouches du projet
était dans une une dynamique très
volontariste de la part du gouvernement
parce qu'il n'était pas évident de
trouver un créneau d'examen d'une telle
loi sur Mayotte il a fallu vraiment une
volonté politique forte pour dire ben
voilà dans
au Sénat que je vais apprendre que le
calendrier parlementaire est très très
chargé et bien il a fallu beaucoup de
volonté pour dire mais on va identifier
un créneau et on va faire passer quelque
chose sur Mayotte parce que c'est
important et chacun pourra y contribuer
en termes d'enrichissement puisqu'on
était un stade du processus qui
permettait bien sûr de rajouter beaucoup
de choses ou de les modifier et donc on
l'a regretté je vous dis franchement du
côté du ministère des Outre-mer parce
qu'on a sollicité je le dis parfois de
façon un peu triviale la moitié de
l'administration française nous a eu
je vais tomber de la trivialité dans la
famille hérité nous a eu sur le dos
pendant des mois et des mois et des mois
on l'a dit mais là on a vraiment un
territoire qui nécessite que tout le
monde se mobilise et les administrations
je pense ont joué le jeu la preuve c'est
quand dans un temps record le projet
doit a été constitué ce n'était qu'un
projet c'est à dire qu'il pouvait encore
évoluer bien sûr c'était le rôle du
Parlement que de le que de la modique de
la mandée que de le faire que de
l'améliorer bien entendu et puis voilà
on peut regretter que finalement ça ne
soit pas lié à son terme mais c'est pas
parce que ça n'a pas été fait que ça ne
mérite pas éventuellement de revenir sur
le métier et pourquoi pas de trouver de
nouveau les voix des adaptations qui
pour Mayotte en particulier
devront être adoptés parce que tout
simplement Mayotte le mérite et Mayotte
le nécessite
les
alors là je vais parler sur sur la
globalité des dromes les autorités de
gestion en règle générale
sont constitués par les collectivités
donc il leur appartient de faire des
choix sur l'affectation
qu'elle souhaite décider
sur la répartition l'utilisation des
fois européens qui leur sont confiés
ce que ce qui a été ce que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure est une question
de fond potentiellement mais nous sommes
dans une situation où on ne peut pas
dicter
autrement que dans le cadre de la
programmation telle que définie par les
institutions européennes et puis ensuite
dans le cadre
national qui en est une déclinaison pour
chaque État membre au-delà de ça on ne
peut pas décider pour les autorités de
gestion
cela dit je mets je me mets
volontairement enfin volontiers dans
votre dans votre démarche l'utilisation
des fonds européens
pour le cas spécifique en tout cas de la
gestion des déchets est un levier très
important
qui est
est mobilisé c'est vrai qui pourrait
peut-être lettre davantage
et donc de notre côté autant nous ne
pouvons pas dicter aux autorités de
gestion constituées par les
collectivités ce qu'elle doit faire des
Européens qui leur sont confiés autant
on peut tout de même les encourager
ne serait-ce que par l'orientation de
certains cofinancements le soutien
en termes d'ingénierie qui peut être
apporté sur tel ou tel type de projet
on peut les aider peut-être à favoriser
parce que c'est nécessaire cette
thématique des déchets donc
oui madame la sénatrice c'est une
dimension qui est qui est qui est à
prendre en considération ensuite les
forces européens sont d'une gestion
particulière non complexe on le sait
alors je veux pas me faire à la fois
une avocat il me procureur de quoi que
ce soit et de qui que ce soit mais
là je vais peut-être un petit peu
outrepasser le cadre de normalement ce
que je devrais me contenter de dire mais
je comprends que parfois des
collectivités hésitent à aller dans dans
la direction de la mobilisation des
fonds européens pour telle ou tel projet
ou dans tel ou telle thématique étant
donné leur complexité il risque
inhérents qui peuvent être liés à ce qui
serait impossé théorie considéré comme
une application insuffisamment régulière
rigoureuse indiscutable des des cadres
réglementaires produits par l'Union
européenne donc parfois les
collectivités hésitent à y aller et on
peut pas vraiment vraiment leur jeter la
pierre parce que c'est
il y a un risque pour elle voilà alors
il y a peut-être des évolutions de ce
point de vue là à chercher
mais voilà c'est les Européens méritent
d'être davantage utilisé et on peut
comprendre que parfois il y a des
hésitations de la part des collectivités
territoriales
les critères pour certaines dossiers
sont trop difficiles à remplir d'où
cette complexité et aussi le fait qu'au
niveau de tous ces fonds européens on a
eu toujours enfin depuis quasiment 8 ans
où je siège dans cette commission c'est
toujours difficile à mobiliser les fonds
spécifiques européens pour donc les
départements ultramarins on a toujours
des des combats et des batailles donc
amené sur ce secteur là en revanche pour
le secteur déchet ils sont inscrits
quasiment dans le droit commun si j'ose
le m’exprimer ainsi si ce même si c'est
pas approprié dans le droit commun donc
par rapport aux sujets spécifiques des
des déchets comme pour tous les
départements il y a accès mais il y a
accès par le cheminement du dossier
classique et c'est là peut-être que je
rejoins madame de Sidrac là-dessus Marta
on peut peut-être donc voir comment
l'assouplir mais déjà ce sujet fonds
européen liés donc au département
ultramarins quel que soit leur
spécificité c'est chaque fois un combat
pour pouvoir donc
avoir le type de crédit voulu parce que
chaque fois il y a des des batailles
mais je suis je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous madame la sénatrice
c'est tout à fait juste et au-delà des
de la satisfaction des critères qui
permettent éventuellement la
mobilisation y compris par je remets les
emails comme vous le droit commun de
leur de cette utilisation il y a
également des effets liés à la rigueur
des reportings enfin des des retours
reporting c'est un anglicisme
pardonnez-moi des retours qui seront
attendus à posteri une fois que les
choses sont lancés que potentiellement
les crédits ont été accordés qui parfois
mettent en difficulté les collectivités
territoriales en particulier en
outre-mer parce que cette ces retours
sont pas toujours facile à fournir et
il faut bien le dire la
comment dirais les autorités supérieures
de gestion des fausses européens sont
très sont très rigoureuses quoi voilà
peut-être plus que les autorités
nationales sur d'autres types
de financement
qui sont discutés et
attribués au niveau national voilà sur
la TGV puisque je pense que vous allez
de nouveau vous intéresser ou ça va
revenir dans une autre question très
probablement mais également sur la
filière REP et sur l'utilisation des
déchets
enfin l'utilisation de la gestion pardon
des déchets particuliers et notamment
les échelles dangereux dans l'ordre que
vous le souhaitez Jean-François
[Musique]
merci pour mesdames les sénatrices et le
sénateur pour pour ces échanges et
ces questions en effet sur alors par le
volet fiscal qui est un des moyens
d'agir et sur le traitement des déchets
mais qui renvoie voilà aux questions
plus globales que l'on a pu aborder
potentiellement dans des auditions
précédentes mais en effet c'est bien d'y
revenir bon sur la TGAP je vais je pense
que
par les propos tenus tout à l'heure de
mon côté
de la DNF de la DG OM et puis des
échanges voilà je vais pas revenir
dessus étant donné que voilà j'ai pas de
propos complémentaires mais on est bien
conscient en effet des difficultés voilà
dans dans les territoires sur sur cette
gestion
de taxes et son poids dans les finances
locales
voilà j'avais parlé tout à l'heure de en
effet de
des actions en faveur de l'économie
circulaire et des déchets par les
investissements potentiels fournis par
l'ADEME par les fonds européens
des fonds européens qui sur le programme
précédent de 2014 à 2020 les fonds
fédères ont donné sur la problématique
et périmètre déchets à peu près 156
millions d'euros
avec des territoires qui ont plus
bénéficié que d'autres par rapport aux
critères établis par rapport en effet
voilà au consensus politique sur tel ou
tel dossier
et je
il est vrai alors je vais me faire
peut-être l'avocat du diable étant donné
les propos précédents sur sur le FEDER
bien conscient de l'exigence des retours
européens sur les dépenses pas forcément
le fait d'air mais sur les autres pourra
européens qui sont très contraints et
qui peuvent favoriser plus facilement
des grosses ruptures qui ont les
insolites pour avoir les équipes RH
derrière pour y répondre et obtenir le
versement plus rapide ça c'est sûr c'est
le biais de ces dispositifs là peu
potentiellement mais il y a aussi là
dessus sans doute avoir conscience
et bien que on a encore
pour les pour les rupes donc font partie
nos territoires d'outre-mer et bien des
critères complètement
assez large qui ne qui offre la
possibilité de financement de CSR
notamment ce qui n'est plus possible en
hexagone voilà et voilà alors après
voilà c'est il faut voir toute la chaîne
tout à fait mais c'est vrai que côté
fonds européen voilà sur spécifiquement
là-dessus on va dire que
il y a il y a également des possibilités
mais qui sont qui sont exigeantes et
j'en profite pour rebondir sur les
propos de sénatrice de sidach sur sur le
fait que
avec le dispositif des rues de réfléchir
sur des mécanismes en effet
qui permettent d'avoir le partenariat
alors il comprit entre nos territoires
peut-être des territoires voisins pour
avoir une certaine masse critique pour
le traitement des déchets parce que
c'est clair que
pour l'île pour les territoires
notamment les îles isolées ou d'autres
territoires il est clair que les
augmentations même faibles se ressentent
d'autant plus fort parce que et bien on
peut pas
envoyer dans le département voisin et il
est clair que là-dessus alors il y a un
travail peut-être de voilà amener sur ce
mécanisme partenariat par par zone
géographique mais alors il y a un
travail aussi et des actes des travaux
qui sont menés sur la révision du pour
les déchets dangereux des révisions du
règlement des transferts transferts
déchets qui est actuellement débattu qui
a gardé de très près par par la Réunion
et Mayotte
étant donné la crise covid qui a eu les
gros problèmes d'export des déchets
dangereux parce que contrairement aux
Antilles les exports directs en
métropoles sont moins faciles
et donc de considérer que d'accord
préalable automatique des pays tiers
pour l'export des déchets dangereux
voilà c'est mon travail sur sur cela
dans les discussions au niveau européen
mais il est vrai que c'est pas encore
c'est pas encore sorti d'affaires là
dessus et il y a en effet l'annonce d'un
prochain projet de navette pour l'export
d'une petite partie voilà des déchets
dangereux
mais avec directement de métropole des
déchets alors ils font Mayotte la
Réunion
la métropole pour pour être traité
ensuite
potentiellement voilà vers arriver vers
la Normandie je crois
voilà c'est ça
tout à fait
bon alors bon ça fait partie on le voit
c'est c'est des des leviers différents
actionnés il y a pas de solution unique
encore plus dans ces territoires
mais
c'est je retiens la volonté de réfléchir
en tout cas pour pour ces mécanismes ces
mécanismes partenariaux par par
bassin de vie si je puis dire voilà
comme ça avait été évoqué
tout à l'heure dans les propos
sur sur la batterie alors sur les
batteries plus particulièrement c'est
clair que les batteries lithium pour
l'instant on n'a pas la solution de
traitement
et donc c'est des sports voilà
systématique avec ses coups et ses aléas
il est clair que bon on a
là-dessus sur
sur la problématique batterie consignes
REP on est on va dire qu'on est dans la
dynamique
d'utiliser d'exploiter le développement
des filières le renouvellement des cas
des charges pour
pour que les éco-organismes puissent en
grande partie donner des solutions
pas seulement sur le territoire exagonal
mais aussi où y compris en outre-mer et
sur ce qu'on peut exiger pour
l'outre-mer de la part des échos
organismes il est clair que il avait été
rappelé par le très bon exposé
d'acide EVAM tout à l'heure précédemment
sur le fait que
de réflexion a des possibles sanctions
des écho-organismes et autres sur
sur ce qui leur est demandé on va dire
qu'on est dans un temps de passage là de
renouer monte beaucoup de nouveaux
cahiers des charges pour les filières
REP de nouvelles filières avec la
filière voilà produits matériaux de
construction des bâtiments
qui qui va être pleinement
opérationnelle en cours d'année 2023 et
bien
de
d'exiger
par la disposition de la loijec à six
mois de l'agrément vraiment un plan
d'action détaillé outre-mer par filière
et
d'avoir un respect un respect de ceci
ensuite et donc c'est ce sera
je pense qu'il y a des dispositifs qui
seront potentiellement mobilisés à sweat
par l'État pour veiller à ce que et bien
nous ayons des taux de collecte ou de
traitement qui ne soient pas on va dire
de 95% sur le territoire national et de
40 en outre-mer pour faire simple pour
que voilà et se dire bon bah c'est bon
au niveau national on atteint
globalement un taux de satisfaction qui
bon et donc ça c'est c'est vrai que ça
fait partie des points d'attention qui
est rappelé aussi en dialogue avec les
échos d'organismes je sais dans ces
déborations des cahiers des charges
je sais que vous allez augmenter les
taux pour qu'on rattrape à peu près les
mêmes toucs la métropole mais si le
cahier des charges est pas rempli il y a
pas de taxe là
non alors au niveau des dispositifs de
sanctions
alors la taxe est un des éléments en
effet pour faire bouger les choses
et après en terme de sanctions et
dispositif à appliqué bon il y a
peut-être potentiellement d'autres
effets de levier mais c'est vrai que
pour la taxe je reconnais que voilà il y
a pas de
il y aura pas d'incident
très bien
pardon
alors le rapport vernis mentionne quand
même que des dispositions de pénalités
ou de sanctions existent à la marge
certes qui serait perfectible mais des
mécanismes d'amende par exemple le 15000
ou 30 000 euros pour les risques mais
aussi pour les membres des organismes
donc il me semblait que le rapport
mentionné que les bureaux enfin de
l'État chargé du contrôle et les
sanctions étaient insuffisamment dotées
de moyens pour justement mettre en
oeuvre ses mesures
bon je profite et il y en a la parole
pour réagir rapidement peut-être aux
propos de Mesdames sénatrices
donc notamment la question de la
valorisation au niveau des territoires
bon le sidum porte justement un projet
valorisation en CSR sur sur la mandature
bon qui va forcément
dépasser puisqu'on veut on veut profiter
de du renouvellement de la délégation de
service public aujourd'hui donc que
porte le sida avec une fillette de Suez
qui est donc star rura fou
néanmoins bah du coup on aimerait bien
solliciter effectivement les
financements feders ça avait été rappelé
ici ceci dit par rapport à l'enveloppe
qui se préfigure justement sur la
programmation 2021 2027
on serait sur a priori 8 millions
d'euros pour la gestion de déchets et
alors que les 8 millions d'euros seront
à peine suffisants pour déployer toutes
les déchetteries prévues également sur
la mandature alors évidemment la
question de la consommation des crédits
a été rappelé effectivement Mayotte la
partie des territoires qui consomment
insuffisamment ces crédits bon ça a été
également évoqué par Monsieur le
Président de du Nord c'est en raison de
déchets politiques de maîtrise foncière
effectivement ça fait deux mandatures
que le sida essayait de déployer ses
déchets on en a pas encore pour
l'instant mais je vous confirme que là
on va démarrer le chantier pour la
première déchetterie de Mayotte qui du
coup sera inauguré l'année prochaine au
sud de Mayotte et ils sont suivront je
l'espère deux autres qui sont plutôt en
bonne voie
et je me permets de revenir sur la TGP
parce qu'effectivement j'ai mis l'accent
dans en présentation sur les impact
direct que ça ça représente dans les
finances de la continuité j'ai
effectivement choisi le prisme de de la
lecture épargne net épargne brute
puisque effectivement ce sont des
indicateurs financiers pour
l'investissement du cinéma et la
proposition qui a été faite ici bon en
l'occurrence à travers les questions
posées sur notre sens extrêmement
pertinente puisque effectivement au
niveau local
on pourrait les affecter sur
préférentiellement des projets de
valorisation puisque mais du coup leur
réinjecter sur le territoire puisque
effectivement le sidom n'investissant
moins bah du coup ça ferait moins de
d'opportunités de de mettre en place des
équipements de valorisation
mais pourquoi pas à l'image de des
enveloppes Fna DT géré par bureau de la
préfecture gare ou des cils ou des etter
par le stockage général envisager une
enveloppe spécifique justement sur les
projets de valorisation de déchets qui
serait du coup ici mis à contribution
infini lorsque le montage de la
prochaine délégation service publique
serait du coup finaliser prévoyant du
coup des unités de la réalisation en CSR
voilà
vous ne voulez pas pour les Mickey moi
non plus
il ne faudrait pas que par des jeux de
mots on évoque pas le fond vous avez
parlé du travail parlementaire qui est
perfectible c'est précisément le sens de
mon intervention la mission
constitutionnelle de contrôle de
l'action de l'administration nous
incombre et nous avons nous avons le
devoir de poser ici des questions si
vous vous offusquez que je m'étonne que
des chiffres
des chiffres qui sont fournis par les
collectivités n'ont pas été remontées
par le préfet excusez moi mais je suis
en train de faire mon travail
parlementaire je déplore comme vous
peut-être plus que vous que la loi
Mayotte ne soit pas arrivé jusqu'au
parlement cette loi contenait je
nécessite de le dire plus de 75% de
bonnes choses le reste c'était à nous
parlementaire précisément de de la
compléter nous n'avons pas eu cette
occasion c'est quand même à la suite
d'un long processus piloté par le préfet
qui est parvenu à cette échec à
l'occasion duquel le Conseil
départemental a donné un avis
défavorable donc comme vous je le je le
déplore mais mon intervention était sur
un simple sujet un petit sujet qui peut
avoir des conséquences énormes sur la
remontée des chiffres donc pardonnez-moi
de faire mon travail parlementaire de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
[Musique]
oui je le signature vous l'aurez
constaté je n'ai pas du tout la question
des chiffres effectivement on peut
disposer de
j'entends ensuite l'administration du
dispose des chiffres dont elle dispose
parfois si elle est un peu plus de temps
elle arrive en récupérer davantage
si un chiffre n'est pas tout à fait
exact on le dit on essaie on s'efforce
de corriger et nous serons pleinement
d'accord sur le fait qu'on ne cherche
pas à polémiquer ni les uns des autres
ensuite
voilà c'est une c'est une démarche
d'ensemble l'accompagnement du
territoire de Mayotte au-delà de la
question de savoir si on a eu le bon
chiffre au bon moment ou si la remontée
d'information est perfectible ou si ça
peut être améliori ce qui est forcément
le cas c'est un accompagnement que nous
devons mener ensemble et
je pense du côté du de mon ministère de
l'Administration que je représente je
pense que
un certain nombre d'efforts pour
avec tous les autres partenaires y
compris le Parlement mener cet
accompagnement voilà ensuite les choses
sont pas sont assez simples elles sont
pas simples en général elles sont encore
plus compliquées probablement à Mayotte
et il nous faudra sans doute beaucoup de
temps et beaucoup de travail pour faire
en sorte que Mayotte parvienne à un
niveau de développement et
nos concitoyens les administrer les
résidents de Mayotte
bénéficient d'un niveau de service
auquel normalement tout citoyen est au
résident en France doit pouvoir
bénéficier voilà donc ma question
n'était pas du tout enfin mon propos
n’était pas du tout polémique justement
sur les chiffres j'en ai pas parlé et
sur la loi Mayotte voilà on ne peut que
se satisfaire de cette convergence de
vue sur le fait que c'était peut-être
une occasion
qui méritait d'être approfondie voilà de
notre côté en tout cas nous efforcerons
chaque fois que c'est possible
de reprendre ce qui pouvait figurer dans
la loi dans le projet de en question et
puis éventuellement de le porter chaque
fois qu'une occasion ne sera présentée
et quel que soit le vecteur qui soit
présenté justement parce que encore une
fois Mayotte le nécessite et le mérite
je vous remercie oui la défip merci
très rapidement sur la sur la TGAP
pour dire que côté de la direction
législation fiscale on partage même si
j'entends pas le point principal de
notre échange aujourd'hui le
mécontentement sur le nom de la TGAP sur
qui aurait été recouvre quatre taxes
différentes une part composante et qui
qui le cas échéant pourrait être vu dans
le cadre de la recodéification qui
encourt sur la base de l'habitation vous
avez donné au gouvernement et
reconnusification qui a déjà donné lieu
à des redémominations de taxes et le
quand viendra le moment de recodifier la
tgapdc effectivement il est pas exclu
que on vous propose une autre une autre
dénomination ce point mis de côté
simplement sur la sur le
sur les réflexions le TGAP comme vous en
doutez on n'a pas de il va de soi on n'a
pas de mandat pour se prononcer sur le
sujet et la seule chose je crois sur
laquelle on peut s'engager c'est de
répercuter auprès de nos autorités le
les différents points d'alerte que vous
nous avez rappelé aujourd'hui
je voulais juste dans rappeler deux
choses en revanche la première c'est que
effectivement le donc effectivement le
la réfraction les réactions ont évolué
au fil du temps aujourd'hui 75% en
Guyane et Mayotte à 35 % en Guadeloupe à
la Réunion en Martinique
vous évoquez l'hypothèse d'un moratoire
si j'ai bien compris ou d'un dispositif
transitoire
il est de notre expérience il nous
semble que en terme de gouvernance
fiscale il est toujours difficile
d'instituer des moratoires parce que
bien souvent on y rentre mais on peine
souvent en sortir c'est juste un constat
technique de en termes de fiscalité je
porte aucun jugement ni sur votre
proposition ni ce dont j'entends
j'entends les tenants et les
aboutissants simplement du point de vue
du ministère des Finances on a plutôt le
sentiment que quand un dispositif est
pas borné ou en tout cas quand on quand
on rentre dans un moratoire en général
on bouge tout du bien on va sortir
le deuxième point pour confirmer très
rapidement et pour vous qui ont été
tenus sur la sur la composante déchets
de la TGAP effectivement c'est une c'est
une taxe incite
par excellence c'est-à-dire
telle qu'elle est sortie de la réforme
de mise en oeuvre depuis 2019 on a là
une taxe qui est vraiment il y a qui a
une sorte de barème si vous passez
l'expression en fonction des méthodes
enfin qui sanctionner davantage
l'enfouissement que l'incinération qui
donc encourage aurait emplois
différentes exemptions y compris qui ont
été ajoutés pour pour justifier le fait
de ne pas taxer certaines situations
très particulière où il est pas question
de taxer parce que justement ça n'a
aucun sens
et dernière chose qui est très
caractéristique à cette tgapdc c'est le
fait effectivement que c'est le
législateur impose de la répercuter sur
les apporteurs de déchets c'est à dire
que c'est une sorte de taxe indirecte
effectivement dispositif qu'on n'a pas
forcément sur les dans les autres dans
les autres textes à partir de là et ce
sont les connaître tout ce qu'elle peut
être digne notamment par Monsieur Cassan
par Monsieur gironcelle sur sur les
difficultés rencontrer en local pour
boucler le budget si vous passez
l'expression
je voulais juste remettre en perspective
il me semble que le
dispositifs financiers publics en
matière de déchets je pense qu'il faut
les prendre dans leur ensemble il faut
pas nécessairement se focaliser sur sur
un seul
il me semble que chacun a son utilité la
tgpdc effectivement c'est elle a une
vocation incitative à la vocation à
inviter à enfin plus qu'inviter
d'ailleurs
encourager fortement à
recyclage au réemploi etc en tout cas ni
un incinération à plus forte raison à
l'enfouissement et d'ailleurs si on en
parle aujourd'hui et si je pense je sais
pas peut-être monsieur Cassan de me
contredira mais il me semble que son
existence même oblige à
réfléchir à de nouvelles méthodes en
tout cas à se poser des questions quand
bien même on a quand même il y a
d'autres quand même ces problématiques
peuvent être prises par ailleurs parce
qu'elles font que j'ai d'autres
politiques publiques mais le fait est
que la TGA PDG comme d'autres taxes
incitatives comme la tiroir par exemple
pour les pour l'émetteurs à la
consommation de carburant oblige les
oblige à se poser la question et à
développer d'autres formes de
recyclage ou de donc ils sont qu'il y a
trois piliers il y a la TGP
effectivement qui a cette vocation est
statique et comme on l'indiqué qui a
vocation en fait avoir son son assiette
serait restreindre au fur et à mesure
c'est à dire que quand les objectifs
seront atteints normalement TGV chez son
rendement il sera nul
à côté de ça il a été homme qui a une
taxe de rendement ne semble-t-il et qui
va finance à pour objectif de financer
le service public et à côté de ça me
semble-t-il encore le troisième pilier
sont tous les dispositifs budgétaires
que vous évoquiez les outils de l'ADN
les dispositifs des fonds européens
qui c'est le point de vue de
l'administration fiscale mais qui nous
point de vue ont plus vocation à
accompagner dans cette période que vous
qualifiez de moratoire enfin que vous
souhaiteriez voir appliquer un moratoire
compte plus cette vocation d'accompagner
les collectivités d'accompagner les
opérateurs pour justement procéder aux
investissements nécessaires et pour
ensuite
et pour la suite atteindre les objectifs
qui font que infini effectivement la
TGAP ne sera plus supporté
juste un dernier point
sur le sur la problématique
d'affectation puis ça rejoint aussi les
problématiques de dénomination
il existe une notion de signe il existe
c'est juste c'est certain dans le Code
Général des Collectivités Territoriales
une sorte de petite sûreté Gap qui est
la main des communes et qui est limité à
1,50 € par tonne je sais pas si dans les
toutes franchise nous n'avons pas
vérifié si on est territoires
ultramarins et les mises en oeuvre mais
pour le coup il me semble que à la marge
certes complètement à la marge elle elle
elle elle traite une partie du problème
de réaffectation des fonds que vous
évoquiez
je précise bien à la marge
merci si il n'y a pas d'autres questions
et je pense que c'est le cas je propose
de lever cette séance on vous remercions
Madame messieurs pour les apports que
vous avez bien voulu nous faire revenir
et puis le support écrit sans aucun
doute que vous me communiquerez le
moment venu quand vous aurez l'ensemble
des éléments qui seront remontés mais
juste quand même sur Mayotte là où je
rejoins là où je rejoins un nid parce
qu'on s'imagine souvent que les choses
se font d'elles-mêmes la
vraisemblablement un message à passer au
prix du préfet pour que la collecte des
données parce que visiblement si elles
existent je suis d'accord aussi elles
sont imparfaits dans le dans nos
territoires mais si elles existent elles
doivent pouvoir vous remonter
un sujet de collecte
à assurer pour permettre cette remontée
donc c'est un message en tout cas moi je
passerai volontiers au ministre le cas
échéant c'est pas un sujet majeur mais
c'est un sujet qui est important pour
vous puisque vous devez aussi pouvoir
disposer des éléments techniques
nécessaires en tout cas merci beaucoup
et bonne fin de journée merci Monsieur
cousin